une production du studio sf bio venus au
sans fil de représenter parquet semi le
podcast on parle de ce qu'on veut que
nos invités date si tu ph canton avec
moins d'hommes planque
mais qu'est-ce préféré ce sont les
caisses kiss me si vous me voyez en ce
moment le géant qui s'est mis tout le
monde dans mon entourage
un kiss me donne une pièce me c'est
vraiment les caisses ultime et on a un
code promo pour vous autres pieds sans
fil pour 20% de rabais effectifs du tier
aller voir toute leur design
complètement débile
puis procurez-vous un caisse si non en
fait on loue le studio et c'est ici où
est-ce qu'on enregistre fait que s'ils
voulaient partir votre propre podcasts
et pour vous n'êtes pas vous occuper des
la technique vais aller voir sur notre
site web studio sf.tv à sin sommes
certainement cette semaine tous les
podcasts tous les packs à ce qu'on fait
évidemment sont bons il n'y a pas de cas
ce qui se passe quelque chose de spécial
qui est telle qu'aujourd'hui et vincent
vallières les podcasts ont fait
évidemment sont bons mais aujourd'hui ça
et on a vraiment une connexion l'italie
profonde en attendant nos vies dans les
questionnements dans les questions
existentielles
c'est vraiment super puis bien sûr sans
parler de musique avec vincent on parle
de son nouvel album qui est excellent
vincent vélia c'est notre propre
histoire que vous connaissez kiki qui
roule sa bosse depuis très longtemps qui
est fait des chansons qui ont marqué le
québec
puis ils vont continuer d'en faire son
dernier album comme je disais est
vraiment super bon ça vaut la peine de
l'écouter
c'était un grand plaisir de s'entretenir
avec lui parler musique parler de la vie
que demander de plus comme un espèce de
conversation avec nous en disant c'est
comme un voyage d'un point vraiment
vraiment avant d'être blessé au podcast
leurs nationaux comme monster fait que
le podcast est présenté par chance et
une compagnie québécoise qui depuis plus
de 15 ans fait des produits
révolutionnaires de produits pour le
corps des produits naturels à base de
l'huile de chanvre est ce que ça fait
lui le chanvre c'est qu'apparemment que
ça après ressortir les propriétés de
tous les autres produits clés quel que
soit expliqué interagit pardon qui ont
plus de 21 produits révolutionnaires
change ph en a essayé un qu'il aime
beaucoup pas mon ami est ce moi j'ai
essayé la crème musculaire avec un taux
élevé d'arnica qui rend dans la tap pop
ça fait vraiment une sensation de
soulagement vous savez moscou quand même
énormément où vous le savez pas mais je
vous le dis je la prends si vous le
saviez pas je fais quand même beaucoup
de courses à pied puis dernièrement
j'avais une blessure à traiter dans la
cuisse droite puis j'ai commencé à
chaque soir à m'appliquer la crème
musculaire de chambre en massant qui
rapidement la douleur s'est apaisée et
c'est guéri finalement tout ce grâce à
la craie musculaire de charme en fait
puis aussi ans j'ai bu beaucoup d'eau
puis je me suis reposé qui était
d'autres d'autres arguments positifs
pour revenir d'une blessure
on a un code promo pour vous ici qui est
le sans filtre 25 pour 25 % de rabais
sur tous les produits disponibles sur le
site shampoing seo donc chang'e-1 seo le
code promo sans filtre 25
merci la gagne de chambre c'est un
plaisir de collaborer avec le podcast de
cette semaine et présenté par communauto
si vous êtes comme moi vous avez
beaucoup moins fait voiture durant la
pandémie puis on a réalisé qu'au final
on n'avait pas si besoin d'une voiture
qui restent parqués dans la rue que ce à
peu près 95 % de la pandémie mon genre
étaient parqués j'aurais eu j'aurais
très bien pu fonctionner sans voiture
c'est là qu'entre en jeu comme une auto
avec communauto c'est un peu comme un
service à la rb end mais pour les
voitures donc si vous avez besoin d'une
voiture
vous pouvez réserver la vôtre d'avant
sur les 30 jours d'avant souvient
dernière minute puis
vous payez en fait le lit vous payer
seulement à l'utilisation et les frais
comprennent les sens l'entretien les
assurances donc pas besoin de se casser
la tête avec ça il ya plus de deux mille
voitures communauto à moriani dans le
parking ici fait que c'est super
accessible vie je crois que c'est le
temps de commencer à repenser notre
rapport avec les voitures comme dim en
plus comme le tour a plus d'entreprise
qui avait causé une entreprise qui
quittent engagerait finalement qu'un
engagement autant sociale que
urbanistiques et environnementales et
urbanistiques parce que une ville comme
montréal comme québec où comme le lez
lille chaque endroit qu'est de la
densité c'est pas fait pour qu'on aille
tout des autres qu'on soit tous seuls à
nous auto sain possible ça vaut
congestionné l'autopartage ça réduit de
une auto moto partage taux réduit d'is
auto sur la route fac ça aide vraiment
pour le trafic puis pour le lui rebat
l'urbanité l'organisation une
organisation reveal by environnementale
parce que aussi en véhiculant mais
partage ça émet beaucoup moins de ge est
donc ça fait une énorme différence si
vous voulez faire une différence c'est
super bon de d'encourager et d'utiliser
communauto est à 7 c'est un support
partenariat en fait avec communauto on
est vraiment content de travailler avec
vous puis merci d'encourager le sans fil
puis vous qu'ils aient coûté cher que ce
que je pensais le temps de commencer
avant une petite réflexion sur sur
circuit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à rien c'est les six textes qui me font
capoter ce genre créé ces jeunes là pour
écrire de la bombe devant moi c'est
qu'un artiste accomplie le un meilleur
poste c'est pas fait grand chose dans sa
carrière qu'elle a une voix qui est sa
voile on doit quand même singulière quoi
puis moins de voix que j'aime beaucoup
comme pour simple qui s'emporte parfois
un peu trop trop clean lacoste
imperfections le forez ouais mais oui
ces textes sont en abondance et puis si
on a fait des arrangements certaine tout
quand même assez pop le lançant popopop
radio médecin qui pour que ça s'arrête
pas ça reste possible en massepain on
l'entend doute que ces protéines - dz
d'avoir un ton bien une signature puis
c'est fou ça paraît inconcevable a dans
ce sens fait on est tellement exposé à
plaindre musique rapidement que la
seconde que tu entends quelque chose qui
est potes dans le moule c'est un peu
c'est un peu c'est inconscient le cc
comme tu t'entends quelque chose il ya
quelque chose d'à l'interpellent d'une
autre façon c'est vraiment c'est comme
si on attendait un peu
l'intention derrière l'intitulé temps
quelque chose est prédestinée à avoir
été écrit pour jouer à radio métaux ou
alors est écrit juste part d'écrire
quelque chose mais ton album je trouve
que je trouve que ça s'entend que c'est
un album qui a été fait par une gang des
trippeux de musique le type qui vous
vouliez faire la meilleure musique que
vous pouvez
dernier le dernier toute beauté je
trouve vraiment question on sait ça
paraît que ça paraît que ça a été fait
qui le ça nous prend le premier rang
sept et on n'était pas dedans on n'était
pas pantoute d'un globe même que je suis
pas sûr que c'est ce qui nous aurait
mieux servi
enfin je suis pas mal sûr que c'est ce
qui nous aurait le plus mal servi de
viserez fin des tubes un tube après
l'autre ce puissant nous ça nous ça nous
le disait pas de faire ce peintre peint
taux fixe pas les meilleures les
marchands sont possibles c'est comme
c'est comme faire la démarche allant
voir j'ai l'impression de type loi crée
des tubes parce que quand tu dis qu'ils
ont je veux écrire un tube c'est que tu
prend pour acquis tous et qu'est ce que
les gens ont envie d'entendre aussi une
typique est qu'est ce qui marche pied de
succès tandis que la réalité on ne sait
pas on peut être surpris mais je doute
qu'on peut faire entre par les quelque
chose qui est loin d'être le tube est
classique finalement ça résonne parce
qu'il ya un honnête et la dame n'doye
c'est clair c'est clair je pense que
c'est surtout le nay comme un éclatement
des déjantés une pièce le public ou si
c'était c'est tellement différent
maintenant de ce que c'était mais ton
quand j'étais au secondaire des années
90 où c'était c'était même temps un
genre de musée mais le grain tout genre
je suppose que l'hôtellerie maintenant
le betis avait surtout avec le grand
tube tu avais le métal qui fit le punk
qui était comme trois familles puis
c'était comme dans une zone de séguéla
qui sait je me rappelle même que mon
jeune garçon on aimait autant je reviens
faire lundi des bennes des années 110 15
octobre
et puis maintenant s'inventait tellement
ouais mais est ce que est ce que c'est
c'est lié je me gêne que la réponse
c'est oui mais quelle est ta perception
de tout ce que c'est lié avec le fait
que maintenant tu as vraiment accès à la
toute la musique que tu veux c'est dans
le sens où à sim et on t'avait un album
à acheter parce que tu avais économiser
pour acheter ton album puis de ces
gamins qui jouent en acheter un
tu vois pas trop tu prends pas la chance
d'acheter un album d'un artiste que tu
connais poc qui qui peut-être que j tu
prends seul qui connaisse penser le
petit koné pied mais il ya aussi
l'élément que quand tu as un talent est
acheté un disque c'est ma tante may 15
mai via cela considérable rappelle
acheter si j'étais au secondaire ça me
faisait un peu mal sa ferme en picardie
choisi maintient ce foutu start up chez
vous il est utile mais c est que cet
intérêt est quelque chose d'assez
[Musique]
scanner comme aujourd'hui je pense
qu'elle serve pas un disque c'est vrai
qu'on a on a accès à plus mais il ya
certaines musiques à qui on donne une
chance qui peut-être moins grands
dossiers segmentant minutes et coûte 30
secondes n'est pas vraiment dans le mode
et en double
aof à ce sujet mme basset s'ajouter le
tout est accessible mais c'est sûr que
pour décloisonner comme se disent ah
c'est sûr ça a eu un effet j'imagine un
grand effet possible sa muse album qui
mérite plusieurs écoutes pour être
pleinement apprécié en fait le système
est ce que c'est sûr si on a parlé je
suis avec qui mettez moi j'écoute plus
de musique que jamais elles n'ont jamais
écouté autant de musique différents mais
qui coûte pas plus d'heures de musique
mais j'ai compris des musiques
différentes t avant un album je peux
l'écouter en boucle le terrain à savoir
mes paroles toutes les riffs le ticket
avant d entendre ce qu'est ce que ça
revient tout le temps là les aspects
succès ce que ce soit lié à l'âge c'est
quelqu'un m'attende et adolescents qui
est ce qui se passe que tu vas réécouter
a souvent subi le même album
mettons là dans la même chanson c'est
moi moi mungo l'oeil écoute des tonnes
mon golf sur ip it non-stop pendant la
semaine qui précède change de chansons
pileux mais c'est sur le ps à ce petit
mais chez nous les mon père c'était un
trip musical et puis il y avait des
albums a pu savoir quoi en faire
mais je réécoute elimane kane s'est même
j'aurais pu avoir accès à la
bibliothèque au complète et j'avais
choisi les miens puis j'ai écouté là que
tu as raison c'est un homme masqué les
oeuvres lesquels tu tombes soient album
où les livres que tu lis le tic mais il
ya comme une poignée d'oeuvres que tu
tombe dedans petit tu tues tu consommes
de vos petites formes marche pour la vie
- vraiment un cubain en fait ces oeuvres
le je pense sont comme ta porte d'entrée
dans la culture ni apprécié de chacune
de ses oeuvres dans sa boîte des fois tu
auras envie d'aller voir qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui en arrière de train c'est
qu'est ce quelle musique qu'il ya eu
avant pour que ce total band les choses
commençaient la femme c'est comme ça
c'est un indice qui amène un livre qui
amène à un mouvement social à une partie
d'un certain que c'est une beaucoup
comme ça que je suis comme entre hesdin
j'ai approfondi certaines musiques ou
certaines patientes
certaines nous certaines connaissances
culturelles ou un certain désir pour
l'heure en général parce qu'au final
toutes les formes d'art sont qu'un
millier dans les mains quelque chose
c'est ce que tendent comme d'un peu de
contre culture plus dur commence à
écouter justement les grands commencent
à s'intéresser d'être aussi au street
art
moi je pense à t'intéresser à petit à
faire l'ex ont comme au port un créatif
il s'est tu tombes là dedans petit fait
crime qu'il y avait quelque chose qui
existe est la littérature les jack
kerouac selon l'élu de surmonter sur un
le sait comme ce temps là dedans puis tu
réalises qui a un monde complet qui
était comme connectés d'une façon tu
connaissais pas un peu comme
l'impression d'ouvrir la boîte de
pandore quand tu tombes sur sur quelque
chose qui est une référence vers quelque
chose d'autre qu'une référence vers
quelque chose d'autre plus il faut
l'admettre l'impression d'un réseau
national
mais comme très bon décrit exactement
comme enjeu je consomme la culture
l'hommage m parce que comme un de quoi
de viscéral de danse qui tu raconte
aussi le ticket com tellement important
c'est que quand tu es dans quelque chose
puis 10 quand tu es quand tu es jeune
maton quant à 14 15 16 ans tee cantona
en amour des vraies petites et
profondément noter quand même quelque
chose
les indices que j'ai que jamais
j'écoutais hier à m'engager peut-être vu
que j'avais fait avec daniel bélanger
les vraiment super merci pour ça mais
c'est parce que moi c'est un artiste qui
j'ai tellement aimé quand je cours
secondaire puis c'est un peu à cause de
lui que j'ai eu envie de chanter en
français puis si je me rappelle qu'on
allait voir ses shopi et il disait elle
à ils disent à votre micro que qui a
fait son premier disque à quoi je me
rappelle pas ce qu'on dira qu' alors
l'un des dangers qu'il ya presque trente
familles et amis es vieux c'est parce
qu'on avait comme besoin que mon idole
aussi soit 60 soit l'ajout d'un
évidemment y pardonnait tout autre façon
mais on glorifie voir le prodige le
secteur avec cerise haye a fait ses
armes et et non lui c'est comme à
travers son album ça marche plus comme
une belle carrière
en fait y est arrivé il est arrivé avec
un premier disque où il y avait pour en
fait il y avait fait j'imagine plusieurs
essais et erreurs en avant lors qu'elle
est bonne aussi avant des années 80 mais
dont qui sait faire que ça s'est un peu
l'avantagé aussi de débris qui plus tard
on entend dans ton cheminement
pas nécessairement et pour encore un
mois tout petits vivent des fois avec
des disques les chansons qui sont
nécessairement toi ou moi sans complexe
au moins trois puits qui sont qui sont
en fait moins d'intérêt moins d'intérêt
tout court non je peux pas danser assume
ainsi mais c'est ça c'était à un moment
si c'est ça c'est quand même le fun ii
ne fait pas très classe devant tout le
monde a des effets positifs et négatifs
mais j'ai eu la chance de de transcender
soit parce que j'ai un producteur qui
était patient avec moi ce qui peut être
rendu plus rare aujourd'hui les dates
déjà rare à l'époque mais non j'ai eu
cette chance au dos rond dis-je un
patient qui m'ont permis justement de
tomber pidement le rideau retombe encore
pire d'apprendre à apprendre ce métier
juste encore d'études met en doute et du
premier album
un show non non j'en joue tout j'étais
invité sur une émission télé
dernièrement il m'a demandé de jouer
petit guy qui se détruit put aller parce
que tu es dans le rouge capables de je
fais avec plaisir mais qui se détruit
qui était comme mon deuxième single
quand j'ai eu 25 mai sinon des gens me
demandent pas non non mais au moins ce
qui est cool c'est que tu peux plus haut
du premier album après ça c'est comme
juste à mes plus de se jouer les tout ça
plus commencer mon 3e 4e puis sa
pression en vol est taquin
si tu as raison mais c'est un peu
inquiet un cadeau un peu un poison n'est
que télé tu baves les grosses tonnes de
thon cheminement tu les as
et et qui rythme at on bien quand avec
20,7 pour ce prix donne 51 10 à 35 40
d'avoir indépendamment c'est quoi le
répertoire aussi le temps quand même
chaque baril a accru de phoque en alaska
à 19 ans il ya peut être plus mal pris
mais sinon c'est le meilleur arrive même
je pense qu'ils arrivent un peu plus en
plus de postes une caméra comme tu es
questionné sur ce qu'est leur force ou
full à la nouvelle direction met le
monde de suivre peut-être la nouvelle
direction
bélanger qu'ils aient mon mari comme
hard et rêver mieux 2 c'est pourquoi les
jeunes se fait un album qui va marquer
quelqu'un quelque part dans un moment
précis sa vie puis il va vivre une
relation vraiment forte avec ta musique
dans un temps un temps donné comme artus
faut que tu acceptes que probablement
qu'ils attaquent autres à jamais ceux là
aux yeux de cette personne mieux de
cette personne là où peut-être que ça va
venir
dix ans plus tard mais ça se peut que ça
que ça fasse pas ça à chaque à chaque
projet qui sait et c'est tout à fait
normal même si tu leur fais je dirai le
moment les xo est ce que la personne a
reçu ce que te fait à ce moment l'autre
scelle la marque ips a marqué mettons
une génération c'est béton béton
métallique ultime élan que métallique
que met-on fil du temps se réinvente lui
arrive avec un nouveau son âme année ils
étaient des années 90-2000 ti blâme
année c'est la france tout le temps on
veut le puits
après on verra une nouvelle affaire puis
l'homme étant il fonde et magnétiques
l'été qui construisent par une cause
l'idée des vieux albums et et oui mais
oui mais en même temps il vous semble un
but marqué comme les autres marques et
noms dans le passé c'était à ce moment
le fallait que ça se passe si on parlait
de la musique dans leur contexte aussi
se mettait lui que qui arrive avec qu'il
est mort le premier album d'évolution le
ccoc ssl est mort sur professionnels aux
le doigt tendu ce type est factice c'est
vraiment une question de d2 dès qu'un
type idéal mais c'est sûr mais comme ca
péages c'est cet élément look c'est
comme aussi ça la musique vient
l'automne le propos vient avec vient
avec une époque 3 exact puis tu peux pas
toujours te pour expliquer mais c'est
sûr que quand tu es quand essaie de
recréer quelque chose comme ça c'est sûr
que c'est une erreur
c'est super pour moi dans ma perception
des choses aussi de de recréer un
mouvement qui te fait vivre à des gens
il ya 10 ans 15 ans 20 ans tu peux juste
regarder en avant mais tu peux pas
essayer d'être bien traité mais dix
façons le je vois personnellement aucun
intérêt non plus ouais c'est sûr parce
que même en termes de marc fait ces deux
visions différentes de leur site
tu peux avoir la vision de d'or comme
travail de façon de gagner ta vie ou est
ce que tu veux mettre le plus de chances
de tomber en recréant quelque chose qui
est une valeur sûre ou d'or qui va
nourrir puis tu vas te permettre de
cheminée en tant qu'artiste l'origine le
dessus parce qu'il m'est ont justement
ton ton dernier album mais j'ai pas j'ai
pas été le plus grand
amateurs au consommateur de thon nord
aux villes du tarn et le dernier il ya
vraiment frappé une place qui qui unique
métaux lourds pour moi dans dans ma
consommation de deux cultures québécoise
puis ça fait plaisir et on en reparlera
mais mais ça j'ai l'impression que c'est
pas un désir de refaire on va s'aimer
encore non compressé le cheminement de
toi de devenir des tirs de faire quelque
chose d'autre dit accomplir en tant
d'artistes puis comme de fait ça fait
quoi d'autre dans un contexte qui plus
dans ce contexte social je m'en parlait
laisser la pandémie le doute
l'incertitude tout se sait ça fait
ensemble bis ça marche c'est fait que
ses potes pas sur une tentative de
refaire quelque chose de tié bi poin
prennent un blogueur qui aurait pu
réutiliser le vouloir faire des
bâtiments encore je n'aime pas c'est
comme ça c'est arrivé je n'ai pas vrai
je n'ai pas vraiment cherché on va
s'aimer encore une fois que tu le fais
tu sais un peu quel genre de point mais
ça peut peut être faire une fois puis
c'est pas plusieurs fois ça aurait pu
tomber dans la caricature
ben oui jamais été à la hauteur s'est
réjouie c'était des pâles copies de
temps à réparer
ouais je suis sûr que oui sûr que oui
pis mais c'est un c'est vraiment c'est
quand même étrange us ces affaires là
des fois ça arrive hein c'est comme ça
arrive à des moments où tu l'attends
peau tu l'attends pu depuis le bagne tas
d iliad ild et certaines chansons qui
ont qui ont un impact tant pis si c'est
un monsieur pierre robin tu continues
taraude pire
c'est vraiment intéressant ce qui te dis
parce que moi ça me fait ça aussi la
musique et certains artistes que je les
vois cheminée puis je laisse indifférent
je peux quand même respecter la démarche
sans vraiment avoir envie de
l'approfondir le pire mandat ni un
projet qui s'empilent le sais pas
pourquoi je t'interpelle et puis même de
le jeu peut avoir envie de retourner
doit pouvoir avoir avant dans le
catalogue puis de réécouter de certaines
chansons certains albums qui le fracas
qui m'attend jetant sur la terre je
donne aux fans de bruce springsteen mais
vraiment sultan mais c'est un artiste
que je détestais la hisser son énergie à
hisser son lot il sait comment me
chantait jacques selle le ton de ses
prods on attend le bon oeil ou à céder
son gros gros disques du début des
années 80 j'haïs est vraiment vraiment
ça puis aujourd'hui c'est rendu de mes
disques préférés puis parce que je pense
pas que ça s'adresse à moi quand j'avais
j'écoutais d'un de ses albums d 1,90
appel de ghost of tom joad le puits
après seul le disney brasco qui a fait
juste avant un bon oeil la section des
albums plus folk mais parce que fait
soudan sont dans sa cuisine soit 1 4 5
puis ça ça m'a fait très imprudent sont
dans son répertoire puis aujourd'hui
dans les artistes plasticiens des
artistes de qui j'ai le plus d'albums
qui devenait le pida que je suis le plus
est le plus assidûment va quitter ya ce
qui arrive maintenant dans nos parcours
d'autres stars d'être une musique
il faut juste pas un c'est moi je
n'emploie je me sens plus je me sens pas
dans une dynamique d'acier de convaincre
moi quelqu'un d'écouteurs c'est une cote
ma musique écoutée au petit on parlait
justement d'artistes qui tombe à un
moment qui essaient la conjoncture du
du moment de ce qui se passe et du son
qui fait que ça résonne piquionne succès
mes tantes et puis mettons est ce que tu
es capable de l'expliquer le succès d'un
versement encore m au moment où toute
l'équipe a aussi sorti
non je pourrais pollet je pourrais pas
expliquer pourquoi cette arrivée
d'autant plus que non nos références
c'est une chanson qui doit quand même
quatre mille notes vaio 4 minutes 30
même relativement longue gouret pour
jouer à la radio assez linéaire c'est ce
que laissait les mêmes arguments dans le
couple et et dans le refrain puis la
production qui était faite avec ses
éléphantes accueille olivier langevin
qui j'étais restée avec fred fortin et
puis qui est d'un groupe le lit dans ce
groupe galaxie sinon référence de plus
elliott smith avec les quarts en boîte
ait pu dicter à tous ces pays étaient un
ton bilan électrique quand même un peu
plus tôt nains prenant l'axé pas
nécessairement des références de musique
commerciale crois que tout le monde
écoute mais en même temps même quand je
les fait la chanson je peux dans un
moment précis de sa d'yves sa définition
ou sage je me comme le doigt sur sur
quelque chose par rapport à ma vie
personnelle a donné on a misé sur le 10
puis après ça c'est devenu ce que c'est
devenu un métier de quand on le fait
mais chanter que j'avais une bonne toune
c'est le chemin des jeunes bonne chanson
qui moi me touche mais de là à penser
que ça peut toucher beaucoup beaucoup de
gens c'était beau c'était vraiment pas
d'amis très parce que quand tu penses
justement quand tu pensais lieu timide
tu penses à des affaires qui si elle y
est timide de touch et touch par un sac
à main mais ne pas toucher dans mon
enfance à masquer exactement sol qui
comme une sorte de musique appris à
prier india pti vous sais comment c'est
comme un genre de cirque restreint qui
ont vraiment été ceux qui ont écouté à
côte il s'est hissé très l'ofas
un très petit rets autoproduit pierre et
fac c'est vraiment cela mais comme point
de référence à sa main très grand public
tout le monde connait de faire une toune
de même est ce que c'est juste du
positif ou à m'amener sacré un genre de
sacrés des attentes ou sacrées déjà faut
absolument à jouer en show ça crée des
tests pour faire une toune de metz qui
est ce que ça vient avec
ou si un espèce de bain pour certaines
personnes battant vallières ses sorties
ou es ce que ça amène son ou toi csu
school que samedi mais c'est avec le
recul le tuer en jeu pas en parler
différemment parce que ça fait déjà
c'est quoi ça fait 10 tous besoin que la
chanson était inquiet même mois avant
cette chanson là si on se reporte dans
dans l'histoire c'est ça le disque c'est
sur l'album le monde tourne fort de ce
qui paraît en 2009 avec mes deux dix
précédents m'avait permis de trouver un
public mais quand même mais assez assez
grand mais port de l'oas que je sortais
de chez nous puis j'étais relativement
inconnu mais je peux jouer beaucoup
j'ai fait ma vingtaine à jouer dans des
parties universitaire n'est parti siège
l'appui après ceux des petites salles de
spectacle pis ça vraiment grandi on a
vraiment fort j'ai comme ça avec mon
band très old school dans ce sens que tu
vas dans une ville de retrouver dans une
autre ville tu retournes dans une ville
puis abandonné les gens ce matin à
à chanter les chansons puis aussi comme
forger une personnalité de bonnes bien
mais quand ça c'est arrivé en 2009 les
monts 10 d'avant je l'avais trouvée on
dit je pense comme proches 40 mines même
rythme quand même beaucoup mais si
j'avais des invitations at-il et puis on
commençait à l'attraction away puis à
être m'attendais tête d'affiche dans
certains festivals poli plus guérir mais
fait j'avais comme un fan bei qui
étaient là qui était qui existent et qui
me suivaient pour un pour certaines
raisons mais quand il ya eu on va
s'aimer encore plus a vraiment ouvert
sur un autre public pour le mcs
plusieurs personnes pensaient que
c'était mon premier disque patrick ma
première chanson là ça a vraiment
vraiment ouvert complètement d'autres
choses que je pense qu'une partie du
public qui est pas de mon public de
meudon mon public des années domaine qui
avait pourtant envie de se retrouver
dans un centre culturel un mercredi avec
des madame qui ont acheté des débits des
bâtons des passes de saison
tout était dans une série de fonds n'est
pas beaucoup à connaître ce prêt à mener
tout le monde est au chaud je peux très
bien comprendre qu'on a gagné il ya une
partie du public qui a un certain âge il
ya des gens qui sont super contents de
voir que ça acquiesce house pour tous
qu'il y en a d'autres qui ont envie de
garder ils se retrouvèrent dans un
certain type de musique plutôt bien
servi à rien ce qu'on dit si tu évolues
fait moi j'ai comme juste écouter ce qui
se passait autour de moi ma vie avait
commencé à changer aussi une tâche d'une
maison puis on a jamais des enfants puis
je t'ai eue je t'ai pas même place n'ont
plus que cinq ans avant donc la la la
musique que je faisais il ya cette
chanson mais toutes les autres chansons
de cet album j'ai commencé à parler
d'autre chose
je pense tout à fait la chute le jeu là
la suite la suite logique sauf que
moussa à l'intercours c'est une langue
un long dhainaut pour dire qu'à
l'intérieur de mon quand même il a fallu
que je fasse une sorte de c'était comme
le deuil de ma vingtaine ou si c'est un
drôle avec mon band avec port d'attaché
pad attache pas vraiment de des attentes
c'est celle que nous on cultive et nice
était pas du tout il n'ya pas d'attendre
commercial par rapport à un mot pas d'un
fake souhaitait comme une liberté totale
pierre monet du bateau de studio québec
il ya ce qui est arrivé le fait comme je
t'ai je n'étais pas un an peut-être un
certain temps mais je m'en rends compte
a pris un peu peut-être en réaction par
rapport à ce que c'est que je suis quoi
- dans la donne ce qui s'y cache est en
train de revenir je deviens dessus ce
qui est juste que je veux devenir pied
bien lointaine je me trouve
ipa chanceux d'avoir vécu ce n'est pas
beaucoup d'artistes qui ont qui vont
vivre un très très grand succès de
demain si je gagne un compte en banque
quand même je suis très content d'avoir
dans son véhicule puis je compte en
avoir touché beaucoup de gens avec ma
musique
une fois qu'on s'y disent tout sur bélon
rendu 10 12 ans plus tard quand je fais
le dernier disque le complètement
complètement ailleurs très content de
chanter cette chanson le tout est soit
entier puis avec beaucoup beaucoup de
plaisir puis mais en même temps sachant
que ma musique continue d'avancer donc
je sens que j'ai comme un peu j'ai
survécu à son nom mais j'aurais pas ça
aurait pu tuer ma soeur ma carrière on
voit des exemples dessus des gens qui
sont plus capables de de vivre avec ceux
de l'europe
ben c'est surtout un an je pense par
contre que ces commandes y attendent
aussi ça t'arrive à ton premier disque
avant
t'es peut-être moins armé pour pour
faire face à face à tous c'est quoi
c'est quelqu'un de 4 pas fait assez de
guembri on nous demande de faire des
gains mais comme tizi ce exceptionnel
vraiment plus de personnes qui peuvent
se vanter d'avoir écrit une toune si
c'est une thune marquantes de la culture
québécoise de ce tronçon de dollars pour
toujours d'armes allant dire je sais pas
si c'est sûr que c'est ça évolue pied
mais c'est vrai qu'elle est si je me
rends bien compte qu'elle a encore un
impact je pense que oui dans la culture
c'est l'ensemble des personnes me
tombent toutes personnes qui parlent la
langue maternelle est le français
maintenant au québec qui dans l'ensemble
mafieux qui regardent de fredonner leur
synode en jouer ceux-ci ses propres et
une poignée de chansons le au québec
j'étais dans une école primaire
miam miam qui enseignent comprimant puis
je m'en vais dans sa classe des élèves
de 6e année donc ils ont ils ont 12
ils ont l'argent on va s'aimer encore
fac et benzema
quand j'étais petit c'était cela me
berçais piemme junte et on va seulement
confection c'est vraiment fort pour rire
quand je fais la moue devant classe et
puis moi c'est ça ça me touche pareil
c'est un rapport locale qui est établi
un ccd enfants le seuil était ils sont
nés quand la chanson exact c'est mon
siège déplore le seul mais c'est la
preuve qui est il une nouvelle
génération qui arrive qui connaît ça
tourne ça faisait quatre ans on sait
pourquoi mais c'est comme et ecoutez-le
peu après ce temps quelques nouvelles
barges qui arriva on l'oublié le sait
vraiment
nous voulons c'est vraiment le plus
grand défi tient sa dont tu parles
ce qui m'attend le loup en réchauffant
bélanger ce cas les cowboys fringants le
réussissent à face moi j'appelle souvent
la tour de l'horloge 225 plume
latraverse a fait ce peu d'artistes
beaucoup d'appelés mais peu d'élus qui
comme aller ce qu'une nouvelle
génération accroche a atteint musique
c'est c'est vraiment pour moi c'est là à
réussir ce si c'est vraiment le plus
grand le plus grand défi des fois c'est
des choses qui étaient que sous le coup
un succès mais qui épaulent le heat le
international du quai paul à la plus
grosse affaire mais qui vieillit bien et
qu'on redécouvre plus tôt et qui m'ont
dit viens classique tandis qu'ils
surmontent une pop québécoise des années
80 qui joue à radio france a nommé qu'on
a complètement oublié je peux pas été
nommé parce que je connais pas mais
c'est certain le type qui a eu aussi peu
de choses qui sont qui ont un gros
succès qu'ils sont mais sont vraiment
tellement ancré dans d'un saut dans le
temps de ce moment le quai après le test
du temps il lui donne moins raison ce
qu'il ya vraiment des il ya des
allers-retours je trouve aussi par
rapport à ça je n'explique j'écoutais à
la télé des lycées 6 des baladins qui
joue entre autres la musique du groupe
de ce mythe du groupe des années 80 que
on n'a pas entendu parler de ce band le
pendant 10-15 ans et quand le banc des
morts un peu appuyé apprécié la musique
grunge est arrivé puisque son lot est
devenu vraiment complètement obsolète
dans la culture puis le au travers d'une
nouvelle génération qui qui voit des
références à des sons qui qu'ils aiment
mais le bâillement de la musique revient
avec un
associé à des images puis a donc à la
culture actuelle actuelle puisse à faire
revivre ne donne pas cher de la peau de
musique il faut vraiment on sait pas en
fait il ya vraiment ça s'il ya vraiment
des phases là dedans petit icc ça me
fait presque rire des fois de voir ça
quel point mettons sécher pour le
mettons ce temps si tu mets ton chez pas
le prog c'est peut-être pour amuser qui
chez les geeks la musique et c'est comme
outil qu'est comme quatre ans par an ce
qui sort pas grande influence progressé
mettant dans le paysage mais dans dix
ans le bilan va capoter là dessus et
puis là on va les attendre un peu plus
dans la nouvelle musique qui se fait
déjà ça at il des folies sont les années
89 à la mode de x factor c'est toujours
comme un opposition parce que tu
regardes mettons les grandes années de
pink floyd et les longues très longues
chansons de led zeppelin au mieux d
incendie secours via vrais solides et
bad prépare un peu comme m tom petty and
the heartbreakers sic camps sont armés
aux autres y étaient justes il faisait
des tonnes de deux minutes une mini 3
minutes qui arrivait dans un endroit
frais ou y arrive hors frais rapidement
parce qu'ils étaient et carré blond cela
en fait des tonnes de beurre et leurs
parents qui se pose à quoi puis
puis ça donc ça comme krill ses
productions le vraiment très très très
élaboré avec des longs build up mais le
contrecoup de timmins c'est l'arrivée du
punk est un peu longtemps pris quelqu'un
comme lui pour partir au québec ou si on
le voit très mettons qui me semble une
couple d'années c'est la chanson folk
était vraiment à son apogée on dirait le
des trucs un peu plus soft et
l'acoustique pileux on dirait que la
plupart des artistes c'est quand même
aux beats est quand même en guinée
joyeux souvent quand même assez avec des
claviers le tipi puis l'europe puis ça
s'est quand même année ont poncé coeur
mais ta moan et c'est comme ça qu'ils se
sont liés trop exploitées ont fait une
nouvelle affaire presser ses influences
d'autres thèmes et on l'est des petites
antilles et le sont aussi
blade & soul et pop jazz adaptons les
louanges on l'entend de plus mais mais
mais mais mais c'est cool c'est cool de
suivre sur l'idée d'écouter suffit
d'aller si je trouve ton album aussi ça
s'entend ça s'entend que ces dix guides
des musiques en fait si je trouve pas ce
que parce qu'il ya certaines références
quand même claire londres presque des
clins d'oeil sont déjà des ligues des
guetteurs à la beatles mettant une tonne
de ces puces et la caisse je suis comme
toi tu excelles avec la douce corps
communs vraiment un thème un thème de
cette époque les gens de la rue qui
comme un un dos ce qui des sports en
laminant qui est comme un thème
universel d'à peu près cinq chansons
effective moi quand je fais sur chemins
dispo à et est en train d'arriver
écoute le thème les huit ans et je vois
rouge mat inscrits soit compris
comprennent que d'un coin dans quel
genre de trip on est c'est fait
à la 12 cordes externe est une sorte
d'hommage dans la chanson à un santé
j'ai beaucoup fait soudain j'ai beaucoup
fait sonar dans ma musique peu après
sommet c'est la façon de la façon de la
capite comment on fait pour capter ce
pour que ça soit le plus le plus vrai
possible taxe et on a beaucoup beaucoup
travaillé beaucoup travaillé là dessus
du petit ya personne qui qui réinvente
la musique au conflit dans ce sens qui
titille tellement musique qui a été fait
le je pense que si ou tu vaux puiser c
était une inspiration qu'elle mélange
philippe de quoi tu t'inspires puissant
plus sacré ce métissage l'écrit quelque
chose de nouveau métier à moins de faire
de la musique contemporaine expérimental
je dis ce que tu fais déjà été fait
d'une certaine manière faut juste
trouver une nouvelle triste nouvelle man
up i c'est cette grippe ce qu'ils font
n'est acquis et kick qu'est-ce qu'on va
écouter dans quel trip compte qu'elles
sont con con con con quelles références
on va aller chercher jusqu'à dessus
comme quand tu comprends ce que tu
expliquer le pic est il accepte ça donne
une liberté vraiment très très grand au
niveau de la création de ces 1/4
comprend que prend le max paux blocks
pour moi qui vont réinventer la roue l'
on part de l'idée que c'est pas ce qui
va se passer mais tim cain quand j'ai
commencé c'était la culture était
tellement pas ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
qui lit les références étaient pas du
tout les mêmes leçons aux leçons n'ont
plus aujourd'hui le en voilà la nouvelle
génération la plupart des gens qui font
de la musique qui joue pas du temps il
joue d'aucun instrument mais loeb et
joue du laptop
mais on joue vraiment bayern en fait un
outil créatif ou vraiment intéressant
cette fois ci ce qu'est ce qui se passe
dans la culture je trouve ça vraiment
vraiment intéressant mais ça fait en
sorte comme comme se le dit que l'âme
l'école de 12e et si ce n'est plus
c'est comment dans les années 90 c'était
ce qui se passe est rejouer de la
guitare
tu t'appelais as tu gardé
potentiellement ton nom pis tu te tues
tu grandis c'est là dedans des solaires
c'était cela la culture puis le main ça
comme ça implose et ses deux mines
d'autres choses c'est devenu ma temps
pour un artiste comme les lits nouveaux
matonga bouchard ou un qui est vraiment
plus dans une tradition plus proche de
deux chansons anglophones exact en
essayant ça fait plus légion le sud il y
en a pu tincques sud
des comme ça ça va revenir c'est en
nature mais c'est devenu c'est ce qui
est un peu devenu minoritaire
ces banques auraient aussi tu es là la
chanson guitare a tellement pris place
dans la chance dans la chanson
québécoise que c'est bas normands gamme
en d'année incité ça soit plus houleux
leçon mines string que ce soit d'autre
chose puis qu'il ya des artistes qui
aiment qui connaissent du succès grand
public qui viennent pas du tout de suite
traditions leur musique s'inscrit dans
d'autres choses dans d'autres références
puis moi je trouve ce je vous souhaite
tout à fait sain pour une culture
qu'elle soit ce qui se passe c puis ça
fait c'est le balancier mandanne et ça
ça s'en va et ça revient piscénois
recyclage est encore plus de goût de
génération haga bouchard qui qui rappe
qu'il a maintenant la ccsa puis ça nous
fait écouter si on a parlé maintenant
récemment avec les journalistes le c'est
mon coup dessus qu'ils n'eussent le
podcast sceptiques un groupe d'amateurs
de rap et aimait tant la réalité que que
l'ego de rab de street rap mort et ali
mettant ce qui parle dans cette toune
céder une réalité d'un nouveau québec et
méthodes moines ailleurs 30 ans puis ont
grandi dans la ville de québec
je connais pas mais qui existe et piqué
maintenant il ya des gens qui étaient
comme toi dans tes études tu parles de
ce que tu connais d'orienter l'oeil
comme un nouveau un accès à un nouveau
québec où se trouve à sa musique
c'est quoi parce que c'est vraiment je
pense la chanson la somme le ton sur ton
dernier album cd souvenir qui sont liées
quand même au développement des plus
vieux que moi fait que ce ne sont pas
eux qui sont pas exactement les mêmes il
mais l'idée est lié un peu au québec que
je connais le type moins à mon passé est
là mon espèce de terroir le pied à moi
les souvenirs de jouer dehors abidal et
l'odeur de feu le bois tout seul puis
c'est vrai que l'on découvre en ce
moment c'est comment keynote apple sait
pas l'expérience de tous les québécois
se dit c'est vraiment intéressant de
pouvoir voir si c'est de pouvoir
comprendre que dans le fond c'est vrai
que moi avec un char take me soro au
valinouët pour aller faire mon igloo
d'or laisser y en a même qui ont jamais
fait timide mais mais mais pas par les
joueurs qui dort c'est quand chris semet
jeunesse les douaniers mais j'ai même
respirer dans cette cette chanson je
m'en fais beaucoup m'ont fait beaucoup
parler parce que parce qu'ils sont des
souvenirs si j'évoque là dedans dit
souvenait très personnelle de la fin de
ma petite enfance qui m'ont emmené
jusqu'à jusqu'à l'âge adulte
puis samedi les sonnets qui m'ont forgé
- mais je m'en contre qui on le sait a
forgé sa fille et d'autres m'ont
réellement c'est tellement en guillemets
gros guillemets universel pour le pour
les québécois rrq qui ont vécu mon
expérience mais je veux pas généraliser
mais pour les québécois qui sont n'est
peut-être pas pas à marier avec son
petit une telle pelouse la région attend
et j'ai moins de six dates de cette
époque là aussi le fait que tu nommes
même les dates dans ta toune 17 ans
quand tu dis je finis mon primaire fin
81 - mais la personne qui finissait son
primat fin 80 aussi à jeudi à arlit
directement depuis leur as à la ramène
moi je faisais moi-même potes se voit
même pas parce que moi c'est pas du tout
le souvenir est qu on dirait que c'est
l'image se mettant pas ce que je
pourrais très bien
appliquée aux titres avec tout ça je
pourrais très bien plus que cela je me
rappelle exactement quand je finis mon
primaire puis que depuis que manet le
vol est arrivé puis que je me rappelle
très bien le point de commencer
comme je rentre je suis sûr qu'elle la
propriété telli souvenait que ce que tu
as vécu moi c'est ce qui me faisait le
plus peur qu'un j'ai je l'écris de celle
là bas j'en disais est ce que justement
ni ses titres au personnage et quand je
lis présente annonce et une loutre faut
que tu ailles lui c'est qu'une balle
personnel tu fait jaillir l'universel ya
beaucoup de gens qui m'ont écrit parce
que tu sais j'ai beaucoup sinon l'avant
dernier couplet le référendum de 95 kaki
et un moment marquant pour les gens de
notre génération parce que j'étais au
cégep quand ça s'est passé près tout le
monde parlait de ce tout le temps
c'était comme omniprésent à la télé à la
radio dans nos conversations on donne
beaucoup de gens qui m'ont qui m'ont
écrit pour qu'ils étaient contents
d'entendre c'est un boulot évoqué c'est
parce que ça l'a rappelé énormément de
énormément de souvenirs
moi ce que ça m'a fait le puits cette
chanson dernièrement
ça fait plusieurs fois qu'on en parle
c'est logique 30 ans puis je commence à
avoir la route lorsque je réfléchis
tiers à mesure si jamais je veux des
enfants qui vont vouloir bientôt le
titre puis puis ça me disent que ça m'a
fait la tonne c'est parce que repenser
vraiment a créé ça me semble une simple
j'aimerais ça parce que ça me ramener à
mon enfance puis a évidemment j'étais
extrêmement privilégiée dans mon enfance
le
de toutes les privilèges du monde entier
mais ça m'a ramené à des souvenirs que
j'avais puis ça m'a fait me demander
crise on dirait que j'aimerais ce
pouvoir offrir ces souvenirs de à
quelqu'un puis ça m'a fait vraiment et
c'est ça ma régis pagniez en deux
minutes les quelques uns je l'écoutais
cette semaine les femmes touchent quand
on dit ça mais c'est un moto puis je
l'écoutais puis j'ai fait un nom que
j'ai remis cette question là que j'avais
mis un peu sur le sud côté parce que ça
passe ça m'obsède mais ça m'occupe
beaucoup ces jours city puis j'ai quand
même ramené dans le fond aussi mon
enfance
ça fait mais ça fait longtemps sauf que
j'en garde des souvenirs merveilleux ses
souvenirs le lg mme rey ce pouvoir c'est
que voir être de l'autre côté du truc tu
es le tout par la tong eux dans ce petit
moi je me rappelle mon père qui venait
me portait à patinoire pour qu'ils me
regardent et puis moi je me demande tout
le temps c'est pourquoi il reste le
temps il doit avoir froid puis lui
brahim à sa retraite il me regarde et
puis il va avoir l'espèce de baisser
comme le laisse les scellés plus beaux
moments de terre de ta vie ou de terre
nouvelle line 50 suivi en affaires comme
ça tu sais qu'un quand je fais des
activités que mes enfants
piqué c'est que mon gars qui jouent à
qui ils jouent au soccer méfie du monde
adam shaw qui joue aussi où un certain
seuil
c'est cesser ces fous de ces fous du est
ce parce qu'il est comme tu te vois être
cette personne le qui l'accompagnent
quelqu'un hadopi c'est un troisième
personne c'est ce que tu penses aussi
moi ça me sall évoque m
moi avec mon père quand j'étais jeune et
qui ont se lancer à bâle où on faisait
des activités ensemble et on allait
jouer au tennis
c'est vraiment des moments des moments
forts le tri qui me titille tout cet
amour l'outil dont tant que mots si j'ai
la chance de 2
davy président hu a cessé de grandir
dans ce qui te donne en fait juste
confiance en ses moyens bien les
capacités fait mais c'est drôle parce
que c'est ce jeu vous écoutait parce que
je savais qu'on a on a effectivement
j'avais vraiment envie de vous connaître
plus sur aux autres pitié j'ai vu que
j'avais à peu près l'ange que que vous
aviez puis c'est ce que tu dis le c'est
pour moi c'est très proches de ceux dont
je parlais tantôt par rapport à un envoi
s'aiment encore celle à la fin de la
vingtaine
le début de la trentaine c'est tout ce
qui est en fait c'est comme le vin votre
podcast ce qui s'est rendu à 15 minutes
au début tu commences d'antan dans ta
cuisine bien aimé ça devient si c'est
une business puis ça devient d'autres
choses pitt évolue plus regardée aux 2 3
1 plus tôt on a fait sopi le petit en
train de sujets un peu c'est quoi en
fait l'eau j'en suis rendu dans ma vie
ma capacité d'émerveillement par rapport
à ce que je fais est ce que ma capacité
d'émerveillement est intact mais où
j'arrive ici bien c'est comme un enfant
juste encore conscient du complètement
du privilège que j'ai de faire quelque
chose mais c'est beaucoup sur un peu la
prémisse de la première chanson tourne
album etc se dévalue un peu sur pied ce
que tu réalises vraiment le wapi que ce
geste est comme un portage comme content
d'avoir fait cette chanson lupi métis et
un nouveau projet le pour moi ça m'a
comme permis de régler bien des affaires
avec moi même puis de comprendre
beaucoup beaucoup de choses c'est que ça
continue le tiche franchement je fais un
show solo fait que je pense tous à votre
fax comme si cette réflexion-là entamées
avec le disque ça poursuit sur la route
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment fascinant
c'est comme de sentir qu une période de
flottement qui comme à lutter plus un
flottement mon boulot tu es comme le
teilleul
il est une période où est-ce que tu le
perds juste cette vraie merveille mal
ben je pense que quand tu quand tu perds
tu t'en as pas toujours compte sur coup
je pense que c'est avec le recul c'est
peut-être à certains moments je n'étais
pas nécessairement dans les meilleurs
jeux pas sûr que des fois je me suis
présenté sur scène au milieu de ma
trentaine dans les meilleures
dispositions dans le sens où je faisais
beaucoup d'affaires si j'avais des jus
l'agent de faire de la radio j'ai fait
de la télé je puis parce que tu j'avais
avant puis j'avais envie de laisser y
badger mais se fait tout seul puis je me
rends compte que ce que j'aime le plus
faire c'est faire de la musique en faire
des chauffeurs des disques et j'ai pas
besoin d'être multi dimensionnelle puis
d'être sûr toutes les laiteries bleed
rybin tout le temps pour tout
qui ça m'intéresse ça m'intéresse jersey
- mais quasiment puces et ça m'intéresse
de me présenter ici devant vous autres
comme chanteur mais pas comme chanteur
animateur
c'est ce que j'aime le plus fin puis je
me rends compte que ça prend toute mon
énergie à être le meilleur là dedans dit
mon dernier disque je pense que c'est
mon meilleur album mais j'ai passé
beaucoup d'un ajuste fasse avec mais
avec mes par nos agents se réveilla ce1
tout toute mon énergie était mis là
dedans et je t'ai profondément heureux
de souci je t'ai pas et je ne chantais
pas que je manquais rien ailleurs fait
que métier je pense que j'ai eu besoin
maintenant de faire ce détour pour pour
me rendre compte que ce que j'aime et ce
que je voulais faire ce test est
piquante qu'un petit de faire la musique
qui les spectacles les dix paires même
temps vouloir que tapha soit plus
d'endroits possibles
c'est épuisant puisque c'est
excessivement beaucoup de temps j'ai
l'impression que c'est le moment où
est-ce qu'on arrête de d'après
il est réalisé au jour le jour la chance
qu'on attend quelque chose qui le
plaisir qu'on apprend quelque chose qui
manquait peut-être un bon en mode survie
des genres que j'ai tellement laura qui
a pas de sens pidc fatfat tout avec le
petit peu pas apprécié les affaires qui
tarit petit jeu sac et un autre de
cocher qui le nex l'énergie mouvement
cgt un bouddha moines puis amman et des
shows ammaniti c'était comme tester
c'était plus fun parce que c'était
s'était tu arrives au choc été brûlés je
suis pas comment sa clé précis quand tu
fais le test de sang ont quitté le jeu
comprend tellement ça prend un temps
aussi c'est ça c'est faux ça prend du
temps que tout le temps t'ennuyer le
titre le temps de deux t'emmerder temps
de mentalement débriefer sur ce qui ce
qui t'arrive sur ce qui t'arrive tout le
temps de penser à ce qui s'en vient tu
es le temps de préparer les enfants très
créative du temps pour ça prend aussi du
temps pour se réjouir de ce qu'ont
accompli les jusqu'en fin que ça j'ai
fait l affaire
c'est l'fun parce que je me rappelle une
certaine époque où j'étais j'ai eu
beaucoup beaucoup de numéros un bac à
bac puis dans vos recherches et la
caisse type il affiche même pas le tuer
cela déposé que les autres plaques le
clament les procédures et sport mais
s'ils admettent est parti c'est une
autre affaire t'as pas le temps de
regarder ta main t-il de te lever le
matin d'un véritable acte qu'est ce
qu'une plaque c'est parti sur une autre
frappe que la plaque tu repenses juste
pour être le président j'appelle se
mettre la terre 1-1 jascha si la terre
est pas dans une sorte de prédisposition
ça c'est rien du sommet les choses dans
une terre où il pourrait vous souhaitez
y figurent c'est un peu ce que je pense
que c'est vrai quand on fait de la
musique mais je pense que c'est vrai
dans dans n'importe quel domaine
peu importe qu'ils n'échouent qu'à plein
d'entrepreneurs qui ferment d'années
vivant comme chaque match tarde toujours
à course mais il ya toujours une partie
dans son entreprise il faut toujours
dans
peut-être qu'elle commun une partie
recherche développement qui continue à
pédaler qui fait comme c'est quoi la
prochaine fois qu'on fait dans quoi ça
vaut s'inscrire et puis ça mais ça prend
pour moi ça prend comme du stop ça prend
du temps rien faire pis je mets ici ses
défauts que la vie te le permettre aussi
tu le moment façon plus vieux des mises
et enfin maintenant quand je tenais à ma
trentaine étaient dans leur petite
enfance fake
ça c'est vraiment j'avais envie d'être
là j'ai envie de toi ok j'ai encore
quand on partage avec d'être le
spectacle je voulais rien manquer de
tout s'était bien important pour moi
c'était plus important que la musique
fait c'était pas un
cependant c'était pauvre step un
sacrifice n'est plus un sacrifice
d'aller faire un bien fou un show en
sachant que je m'en inquiète la fight ou
un une finale où quelque chose lors
tranquillement pas vite comme une autre
porte c'est un autre chapitre on dirait
lucky qui sauve la mon rapport avec mes
enfants c'est là sont beaucoup plus
indépendant et donc ça ça me donne un
ton un nouvel plus de teint disant que
j'avais moins certain que j'avais moins
avant fait que la clé c'est la vie on
dirait qu'il ya comme un autre comme si
c'était vraiment un autre chapitre c'est
quoi qui va s'écrire dans ce chapitre le
terrain ça mais ça m'intrigue c'est
charles de voir ce qui va lui il ya eu 2
c'est super intéressant pour des
questions qui m'habite aussi des lots de
comair du temps puis de deux mois c'est
surtout la question de 15 que c'est
assez c'est parce que tu le disais en et
city prend le manque pour ta carrière
puis le succès de ta musique tout ce que
tu fait d'être sur toutes les tribunes
c'est positif le tir puisque les yeux
plus de monde qui vont te connaître plus
de monde qui vont coûter à musique et
plus de monde qui vont plus jusqu'à
maintenant un effet à peu à l'infini
laitiers puis mettons temps n'est jamais
moi dans mon cas en entrepreneuriat
mettons c'est que s'est t on pense tout
le temps à ceux qui sait quoi qu'on fait
le plugin gong gong au but c'est 15 aces
qui est assez puis je pense qu'il
faudrait du moins je veux pas
généraliser mais le faire pour moi de
normaliser le fait de dire ok a city
cars c'est assez pour pour même j'ai
plus besoin de gros sourire de coin de
croire que d'en faire plus de d'abord
plus de succès plus d'argent jusqu'à
c'est là qu'est ce que tu fais avec ça
avec un c c'est surtout ça moi c'est ça
que j'aime c'est qu'un joueur je
regardais les tombeaux épisode les
sujets auxquels que vous abordez y en a
dernièrement sur le conflit on devrait
au brésil mais c'est comme merci bourse
otc
je me sens mais je trouve ça très haute
mais je présume que pour vous autres
c'est un peu un qu un moelleux comme
consommateur
j'ai l'âge que j'ai fait vraiment
content parce que les questions que vous
posez je me pose la même question celle
d'il un conflit qui comprend pas au
complet ça vient comme une émission de
service mais je me dis quand vous faites
ça vous donnera cuisse il ya du monde
qui vont pas nous suivre
la bataille du rebond note que vous
fassiez ça passe comme un choix
éditorial de kiki où vous vous
positionnez d'une certaine façon c'est
un fait que vous gagnez un public comme
moi qui font craquer segel
il m'intéresse
jeux comme mais patrick et de l'autre
bord le risque c'est que tu peux tu
perds le manque de personnel que c'est
possible mais tu évolues semmaris
société varient pour nous c'est bien
plus nourrissant sur l'éthique c'est
comme ça c'est sûr qu'il ya en termes de
croissance des chiffres on est bien
mieux de recevoir un influenceur le nom
sauf que pour nous en ce qui t as mais
la croissance est bonne on a du monde
qui nous écoute on a plein de monde qui
à chaque semaine sont avec nous autres
fait qu'on va amener ce monde le où
est-ce qu'on veut aller dans des choses
qui nous nourrissent puis en espérant
que sa nourrice les gens aussi un jeu en
mettant juste mais c'est sûr que c'est
aussi par le fait qu'on n'est qu' on est
le métier la conversation qu'on a en ce
moment je trouve que je réussisse comme
une conversation qui est ultra humaine
pile très intéressante pour quelqu'un
qui en a rien à khalis et de de ton nom
c'est quand de vote ici on parle dans le
jeu qui nous touche tous ont pâti fait
comme si seulement vous embarquez avec
nous pour des pour des trucs qu'on qu'on
aime forme
quitte à ce que ça ralentit ce peut-être
la croissance du truc mais en même temps
on sent vous tirant du moins vite et au
final je dire si si on le faisait si les
invités qu'on allait chercher c'était
que pour le chai faute et que justement
c'est d'aider des personnes qui ont
acquis on va éviter cette personne
devant un gros succès influenceurs
youtuber et steve biron mais on met nos
vidéos sur youtube c'est sûr que ce soit
un ultime balle algorithmes en sorte que
ça fonctionne plus petits on en a reçoit
pour le titre final four depuis jeudi
entre les gens avec qui on a envie de
discuter métier si on si on
pervertissent notre démarche ou si on ne
faisait que pour ce bain ou finale en
breton sens pour vous au final pourquoi
tu le fais tu sens que si si t'aime pas
complètement ce que tu fais ou si tu
t'es c'est comme cette session qui n'a
pas une perte de temps ligne parce que
si tu apprécies paul la démarche s'était
pas fier de ce qu'est ce que tu fais
j'ai exactement la même réflexion par
rapport à la par rapport à la musique
quelque chose il
je pense que c'est ça c'est là aussi
quand tu es dans cette zone là c'est
l'opt et le plus inspirant qui sait que
quand tu es dans l'autre zone c2 a
comptabilisé comptabiliser des stades
sous des chiffres ou des streams tpo en
train d'inspirer non je ne trouve pas
inspire non en fait c'est là que ça
devient comme c'est là que ça vient
d'elle est dangereux c'est que la vie et
les vitraux courte ne porte un nom mais
on n'a pas le temps de passer du temps à
pau apprécié ce qu'on aurait une grille
lundi si c'est vraiment une perte de
tendance et d'une vie ce pôle ont la
même si c'est pas profité à disait tu
viens juste une fois ci c'est sûr vient
épauler notre capacité à notre capacité
à relancer à relancer l'action à
comprendre et à qui le jeu tu as faim
d'un jeu la fin d'un cycle
juste à la fin d'une étape c'est quoi ma
capacité à laisser aller à l'éthique du
fini tu finis ton temps secondaire
autant c'est j'ai piloté comme a plein
qui le bond des ménages voile à
l'université un ailleurs j'ai je lance
ma gang de norman king james lassche ma
job qui je relance mais je relance ma
mission oise qui ce qui se passe
ailleurs pied bat plein d'étapes dans la
vie après maintes su survivre
tu vas vivre soutient avec ceux ci mais
c'est comme d'être capable de pour moi
de comprendre de lire certains certains
enseignants y sont restés très intérieur
ce qu'il doit
j'ai fait le tour de ce jardin de avant
que ce soit pour le fun
[Musique]
c'est tellement quelque chose qui est
captée pas forcé de le faire 58 11
secondes en a tous fini une décision qui
était imposé il faut que tu fasses
quelque chose d'autre mais quand ils
deviennent adultes que plus ces étapes
là qui sont clairement définis s'étoffe
de soldes seules de ce coma des fois tu
sais j'ai des amis qui sont qui se sait
leurs propres moules qui sont comme dans
les espèces de prison dorée c'est un bon
job du fait maison et se met la tête il
fait sans quelques 1000 par année pilote
ta ta ta maison payée puis les enfants
puis avec des tops et si tu veux que ça
roule le même avec sa maison là puis ses
activités le tue ses vacances pour
qu'ils continuent dans un stade jean
bleu parce que messi c'est jobs ne s'est
pas pas tout proche du hive que tu
t'inquiètes avait le camp de sortie du
secondaire ou candidats afin de
l'université qui fait qu'en allemagne
c'est maintenant ou jamais le cecil puis
plus tata plus c'est dur plus c'est dur
de quitter quelque chose parce que tu
viens tu deviens c'est plus dur de
prendre des risques je pense un avis si
des affaires qu'on fait jeunes
naturellement rend plus tard dans nos
vies des fois c'est plutôt une théorie
mais après ce type de film et ont
peut-être que c'est des bleus peut être
les sacrifices pour mes tempes caylar
admettant cette personne le c'est
d'avoir une vie tamis puis d'avoir la
maison avec une trampoline en arrière
puisque que aller à la job c'est un peu
les sacrifices pour pouvoir vivre ce
souk et sam année-là jobs prend toute la
place justement habitants pour ce matin
normalement tu passe en temps normal
mais si tu te rends compte assez vite
que si tu tu accomplis pas à ce prix
c'est simple appareil
cette matière
il ne peut pas être le père que tu
voudrais citer pas considère pas
accompli de ne sera jamais accomplie
complètement
mais si tu arrives pas une sorte d'
équilibre le sait comme c'est plus le
fun fait quoi avec tête-épaules n'est
pas le père quelques d'offres mettons la
une la vie qui est qu'il comme la vie
rêvée où la vitesse mais en mettant tout
était pas vraiment dans cette ville
parce qu'ils étaient pointés pour
heureux dans ce que dans ce que tu fais
que ça revient à mais ma foi et quelques
l'artiste qui est plus dans une zone
pour être pour être inspirant s'est fixé
c'est vraiment ses traits pour moi c'est
quelque chose de très très très
compliqué ça c'est vraiment de
l'extérieur des fois ça a l'air plus
simple mais oui mais facile de regarder
crise c'est ce quinté prix tente de se
sortir de cette espèce d'engrenages là
c'est vraiment pas simple mais je pense
que je pense que s'est offert des
check-up souvent pointée parce que si tu
te fais ça à mener des audits et sur le
cruise control de seul pilote
automatique tu fais juste
m'est avis ça se peut qu'à ramener quand
vient le temps de réveiller tout frais
dans quelque chose qui était plus
bientôt
mais c'est que si tu fais des check-up
sur tout le temps sur ce qui était en
train de faire il ya beaucoup moins de
chance que tu te ramasses dans quelque
chose qui était parce que plus tout en
france +6 tour de sortir avec mes
enfants sans guillemets mais plus tu es
plus tu es prisonnier ne tue plus et on
s'en sortir mais y avait un gars qui
était un père mg et côté de la natation
un peu le cache t plus jeune fille un
père de nos joueurs de toute une famille
ne trouve qu'ils nagent et qui lui avait
été pharmaciens pendant trois ans j'ai
pratiqué comme pharmacien mais en trois
ans qui avait toutes ses études 6 quand
même un processus qui est longue le
titre ncaa bresse de pharmacien d'un
instit bonne job était sertie lui amener
à fait non c'est pas sa pente puis était
retournée à l'école étudiant en histoire
de l'or qui est allé travailler comme ça
en programmateur au musée des beaux-arts
à québec lui est fait non c'est possible
c'est pas sa pile après sa série qui met
c'est sûr que tu prends une bonne pécot
mois sauf que christ on parlera précieux
il lui venait à toutes les compétitions
in angers pour les maîtres nageurs ils
sont en train d'être les matins et six
enfants est encore en shape en tabarnak
le vigueur étant un bien surtout je
m'imagine en symbiose avec ces gars-là
c'est avec ce qu'ils voulaient c'est ce
qu'il était chez lui lui avait l'air
complètement heureux il venait le matin
il n'y avait pas besoin de rentrer à
pharmacie les venelles matin doji
cambodge coaché avec ses enfants pilote
ça prend quand même ça prend quand même
tu es un bon une bonne auto critique
pour être capable de faire un check lol
puis du courage aussi juteux mais oui un
courage non pitié jeune fille il doute
l'apprécier maintenant aussi d'avoir
peut-être plus d'avoir été aussi loin
dans ce processus le d'avoir une remise
en question d'avoir fait un 180° il doit
se lever le matin puis se dirige plus
chanceux je rigole le plus bien été je
suis vraiment comme où je voulais être
le type il est gelé fait maintenant
c'est le courage c'est le bon terme
parce que tu sais pas qu'est ce qui sert
bien là après le titre je possède quoi
ta vie dans l'espace de quelque chose
qui était que tous ces gains
confortables peut-être puis jusqu'à
quelque chose qu'il ait possiblement pop
parler de fin de cycle 2 capable de le
reconnaître c'est un peu seul thème de
et les jardins ce moment c'est un peu
sous le thème de la chanson d'après qui
s'appelle tout n'est pas pour toujours
pour moi c'était vraiment sur la la
capacité à alors j'ai prise à la fin de
la fin d'une étape le jardin se meurt
c'est plus le quand ça brasse cependant
comme quand eto'o 35e les relations
entre eux dans la relation est
hep hep hull ont expliqué des capable de
dire c'est le nom d'allah france a dit
il ya 7 heures en choeur qui salit les
soufflets les souvenirs de nos beaux
jours mon amour on changera en course
l'homme s'était tu t'attends à un moment
dit pères lucidité que tu dis je comme
trop en crise pour qu'on se parle
normalement mais c'est ce qui devrait
arriver mais c'est pas ce qui se
passerait donc je capable de jeu capable
de dire que sam que ça marche pas que ça
vaut pu marcher que peut-être
qu'éventuellement on va réussir à
trouver une zone une zone où ça va ce
pouvoir mais qu'elle a visiblement ça se
peut pus tiff au camp cesser ses débuts
ce débile serein et on sera là tout le
monde se rend le mettre autant dans une
relation 16 ans aimait tellement un
pilon se parlent plus efficace par genre
je suis un mes amis david que tu connais
qui a eu l'idée d'y amener y avait été
encore je pense pendant cinq ans avec
une feuille puis dis le à fait plus
partie de ma vie
et puis le du tout elle existe plus dans
mon univers comme ceux de wir il se fout
c'est fou ça c'est vraiment dire c'est
des deuils
c'est vraiment des gros deuil à faire
des gros deuil a frappé un puits qui
touchent à des zac des éléments tic des
fois c'est notre ego qui est touché
notre emploi souvent pilote pas notre
capacité aussi à la reconnaître ce
week-end qu'est-ce comme le blanc c'est
pas le plus beau côté de nous qui
ressort dans ces moments là qu'on change
le plus et si c'était ça le concerne le
temps
non c'est toi à comprendre si tu
utilises être mon appartement t2 tech
deux personnes qui sont tellement
évident qu'ils sont plus capables de se
parler c'est comment bien dire puisque
c'est comme ci ou que ça chie réussi
parce que des fois on le voit juste peut
on noter si comme juste une espèce de
ses ultras subtil sa ceinture
tranquillement permanente réveil des
années plus tard pis tu parles plus ou
tenter de la séduire il ya une tension
c'est fou qu'on semble de mailing
préféré c'est quand y est c'était pas ça
le projet l'était moins c'est ça c'est
qu'il nous semble c'est est pas seul
produit réfléchissant mais cette fois
c'était pas à l'aise quand on sait pas
ce que c'est à dire qu'est ce qui se
passe je pense bien les enjeux de
toujours garder mes amis autour
quand lens danse de ce tour de force de
la vie tel est lé les enfants à la
maison c'est tout lancent comme dans un
rail le cédant 1
une sorte de promesse et espère que un
sens puis tu penses que mais quand ça
arrive pas c'est si c'est une titulaire
un peu dit je pense l'identifier d'une
quand tu dis tout c'est très pernicieux
parce que c'est plusieurs petits
éléments de la vie qui s'additionnent
qui font en sorte que tu perds de vue là
où les personnes qui est que tu aimes le
plus petit des fous tu perds de vue
toi moi c'est ce qui est en prennent vie
c'est vraiment c'est complexe là la
rupture
plus tu avances et je pourrai pas très
vieux métiers plus t'avances là dans la
ville les enjeux de déceler ses matons
alors quand est étudiant au dessus des
fautes habite tu habites paqueta blood
stone son enfer il faut très vite avec
elle mais le canto
dans une hypothèse où la tête tu as des
enfants tu le sais comme moi ou c'est
beaucoup d'heures c'est mme coulter
beaucoup de strates beaucoup d'eux aussi
de deux couches qui explique
l'implication des traitements qui il y
en a qui se dit je me rends bien compte
qu'autour de moyens et en acquis qui
s'en relève qui s'en relève pas ses deux
sauts ou peu ou mal ou c'est long c'est
que c'est vraiment long
vainqueur c'est ses sources et c'est
compliqué fait que seuls 10 des deux
idées de cette chanson le jardin ce
match là mais tu sur le 10 mai 9 au
dessus parce que quand même il ya quand
même de quoi de dire quand même de quoi
c'est quand même malsain senti mal qui
est évoqué ses pas c'est vraiment pas
quelque chose de boules qui existent au
moment de la visite à un moment de la
vie que énormément de gens qui passent
au travers d une séparation difficile
d'une relation long terme qui finit par
se parcourir un terroir ça ça fait
partie de la vie qui est du match comme
je suis très content de me convaincre
parce que la chanson avec sommes au bout
abdallah flirte pas avec que ce
sentiment là à ivo vraiment dedans c'est
de ce côté là ce côté là vraiment moins
bon de nous qui ressort dans quand une
relation tranquillement pas vite c'est
ainsi qu'on sent qu'on sait très bien
avec celui concédé beaucoup comme
pourquoi garder la tête sortie de loin
j'ai l'impression qu'on parle on sait
qu'on parle de nous dans douze ans je
n'ai rien vu
[Musique]
mais je n'écoute encore une fois un
album il y avait une espèce de titres
les enjeux qu'on parle sont au top et
amis présents au fil de l'album utiles
comme les les étapes les enjeux de la du
quotidien toutes ces choses là
il ya aussi l'idée dû moins de kiss qui
m'est apparue l'idée de vieillir pis
d'accepter sur deux vivent avec ça
comment comment comment tu trouves
surveiller ce que moi c'est la première
fois de ma vie que je commence à y
penser
première fois de ma vie que je commence
à regarder derrière moi je fais crise
quand qui vous tient que je vois en
avoir fait autant que j'en ai fait je
vois avoir 60 ans qui je dois être view
à santa selon comment moi je me voyais
quand j'avais 15 puis c'est la première
fois de ma vie que je pense parce que je
me dis que j'ai pas et j'ai pas une
angoisse mais j'ai une espèce de jeu pas
comment décrire le sentiment un espèce
de de nostalgie peut-être pour pour de
nostalgie pour le temps passé puis
l'espèce d'incertitude de ce qui s'en
vient mais tombe pile le fait que je
serai plus confortable dans ma nostalgie
que dans mon incertitudes ne touchent
pas ça fait dix ans que je l'expliqué
jeu mais je me vois veux ressentir ce
nom mais en fait ce cégep à des japonais
mais moi j'ai comme recommencer à main
un match comme je te dirai ben ça c'est
comme mulhouse où j'ai ensuite j'ai créé
un mode en pochette c'est quand même
quelque part j'étais un peu au milieu
d'un milieu du chemin monnaie fictive
comme j'ai vraiment une perspective
assez assez vaste de de ce que j'ai un
fils et mes souvenirs mathon de ma
jeunesse fidèle du début de l'âge adulte
sont encore vraiment précis pour moi qui
joue encore beaucoup de deux plans j'ai
beaucoup de projets qui s'en viennent de
boucler comme lâcher prise par rapport à
ben ben d affaires indien a aimanté
chance ou de deschamps ce droit ce qui a
toutes les chances de faire de la
musique des chances ou d'avoir une place
encore qui est la tienne dans la culture
actuellement c'est un profit de profiter
trifon profil de chacun d'eux
chaque instant métissé sûr que on est
tellement d'affaires qui se passe à
chaque moment comme le en étant un
moment où tu en es tu tu vois des voix
tes grands-parents partir puis après ce
matin en europe des oncles des tantes
martigues c'est une vache minella
d'infecter ses traits pour moi c'est
très complexe
puis je fais comme juste mon mac et
notre journée avance profitant parce que
moult foncièrement c'est facile c'est
assez facile pour moi d'aller dans
l'espèce de zone qui est évoqué le cas
de l'installation de la statue dans
laquelle moi aussi je me sens me sens
vraiment
mais bien puis mai
c'est certain que ça nous empêche pas
d'avancer de cheminée puis de l'hiver
quelque chose ce 1 1
c'est comme ce que je sais moi j'ai
envie de rencontrer le lot j'en suis
dans mon âme mon parcours c'est vraiment
comme au niveau créatif j'avais des
attentes élevées par rapport à ce que ce
que je voulais faire au niveau de la
vérité de ce que je voulais injectés
dans mon projet j'avais des attentes
élevées par rapport à la réception de te
j'avais pu quand j'ai remis les bandes
maîtresses mathon j'en avais plus
latente
je me disais ça me dérange pas du tout
ce que les gens vont écrire là dessus je
vois là j'ai vraiment senti que je te
l'aller au bout de mes demi ressources
fin 2010 mais s'est décantée qu'à toi
t'es fier du lycée que ces bombes dans
tes goûts à toi imputés viole ton projet
après ceux qui ont parlé versus tantôt
de faire quelque chose en ayant des
attentes commerciales tout instant qu'il
s'en prend à y est emprunt se situe fait
avec cette idée le pic en plus c'est
beau c'est le résultat
il reste plus rien jeudi le titre de
tout stress rien même pas la fierté
d'avoir créé quelque chose vraiment pris
mais si ta soupe sitôt rien que ce avoir
créé une oeuvre dont on est vraiment
fiers que c'est toi tu es le bouton truc
d'état démarche qui même s'il n'y a pas
de réception toujours bien c'est
toujours ça vaut beaucoup quand même
mois puis maintenant nous sommes à des
sportifs les deux points puis moi j'ai
fait et je fais vraiment un lien entre
chômage et j'ai couru beaucoup dans les
dernières années bien ses matons qu'un
mois je me prépare pour un un demi
marathon ou un marathon ben ma
préparation a moins je la fais je le
fais pour moi je m'aime je me fixe un
objectif soit importe qui parce que
visiblement je vois pas aller aux jeux
olympiques il
ça va pas arriver fait fait les temps
que j'ai envie de rencontrer ben je les
range ça je les rencontre pour moi puis
ça m'appartient comme de quoi dans la
création qui semble ok 100 kg est
semblable à soucht ce kit qui pour moi
c'est très intimement très intimement
liées parce qu'il dit on se tait on
évolue on change le pied faut pas
s'attendre à ce que confirment des
différents si on le fait pour que les
gens nous le disent ou encore le ca ca
communiqué unitaire été tu fais j'ai
fait pour toi puis un sujet mendy
d'attitude par rapport à la comparaison
que les sports le ca pourrais pas être
plus exact ce qu'ils te disent que moi
tu je me suis déjà entraîné dans
l'espoir d'aller aux olympiques le quand
je faisais de la natation pis même dans
ce processus le si j'avais fait tout ce
que je tout ce qui était en mon pouvoir
pour être prêt demain
peu importe le résultat ça ne m'aurait
pas dérangé fait que j'arrive aux jeux
olympiques que ça aille mal que je me
classe pas que je me fasse ramasser si
j'avais fait tout ce que je pouvais voir
oui c'était dommage sauf que je suis ça
me dérangeait pas parce que j'ai fait
tout ce que je pouvais pas inversement
quand l'avez pas fait
c'est là que j'avais le pire sentiment
marne parce que quand tu n'as pas fait
ce qu'il fallait faire par yves leur
passé commun
tu fais ta performance est ok mais sans
plus de poids le sentiment qui tu
remplis de de fierté puis de donner tes
envers toi même en fait je pensais cela
la clé numéro 1 de pouvoir se regarder
dans le miroir frei tchèque lui qui te
fait te laisserai pas peu de nulle part
je pense effectivement la comparaison
est bonne je voulais qu'on prend un
petit peu aussi
je suis de travailler avec martin léon
ton album - martin léon a martelé ce big
time le fait qu aucun cas de même
cherché il y avait beaucoup de martin
léon qui jouait tout le tapis on
l'entend un peu dans ton album on
l'entend un pack d'akale scheckter des
pour des textes des arrangements mais
dans quelle mesure est ce qu'il ya
participé cet album
ben dans la perspective plus large c'est
la conversation qu'on a sur le bâton sur
le temps qui passe
moi je pouvais l'avoir cléon qui
reposaient essentiellement les questions
comment c'est que ce qui se passe très à
l'étape où où tout était rendu pillet
qu'est ce que je fais qu'est ce que je
fais avec succès beaucoup leon avant
qu'on travaille ensemble qui m'a dit
c'est parce que je me questionnais par
rapport à plein de choses il ya quelques
années on se connaît depuis longtemps
puis c'est lui qui m'avait dit si le thé
peut-être rendu à un temps pour un un
peu appris après six cas ce qui est fait
dans vie peut-être sortir un peu datés
nous femmes prendre un peu de recul
voyager lire puis jusqu'à constater le
chemin parcouru
chose que ce que j'ai fait dans l'est
dans les dernières années qui m'a comme
un pas que lui mais il m'a apporté il
m'a apporté beaucoup son espèce de pas
de recul calme toi came to say printemps
qu'il faut puis encore lui qui était si
depuis quelques semaines trop vite
malien tout le temps tu es comme trop
pressé de
de faire les enfants et puis moi je te
mets n'était pas tellement pas assez
précis c'est comme il en existe par dix
ans ne trouve pas que c'est ça c'est pas
les métiers fait de la musique de film
big n y fait d'autres faits dont
l'enfant puis on a pas on n'a pas du
tout la même vie mais sont à passer ces
conversations là sur la vie qui sont qui
comme intime que kikson2 de l'écriture
de certaines chansons qui amène à c'est
comme la chanson et maliens qui fait un
têtu et têtu conscien de de la chance
que tout d'être facile espèce de
chansons lui ont dit y a qu'à chaque
étape il y avait lui qui qui nous qui
nous ramenait tuer qui nous questionner
pour con pour qu'on continue d'avancer
pièce est un bon exemple est en dessous
de celle à la valeur du travail parce
que c'est pas nécessairement l'artiste
qui est le plus le plus connu du québec
mais ce qu'ils aiment les leurs je
l'aimé énormément puis le travail qui
fait bien pour moi une valeur il ya une
valeur dans le temps
pis et les artistes que j'aime le plus
mince du jem que leur travail
s'inscrivent dans une époque mais qui
est comme une chance de pérennité ban
dans ce qu'ils font on sait jamais mais
il ya comme des clés qui sont là pour
faire comme c'est une réflexion sur sur
l'époque dans laquelle on est ou sur un
moment personnel qu'on traverse mais
peut-être que dans dix ans dans 15 ans
dans 20 ans ça va avoir encore une
valeur c'est un peu seul le déserter
derrière leur le travail que le désir ou
la prétention c'est selon lui derrière
le travail que je fais fait que l'idée
d'un m'associer avec un but comme ça
avec qui je partage je partage je
pensais que c'était vraiment c'est très
tu es très difficile parce qu'il y ait
six tango qui jamais satisfaits et
jamais il recommencera tout tout le
temps mon effectif finit plus encore
comment s'effectuent on était tout le
temps en train de sang de ces chicanes
et mais c'était quand même très très
intenses comme comme ya marie c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qui aime
il veut toujours tout refaire puis man
and in musica il faut que ça demeure
pour moi comme pour que ça ressemble à
ce que c'est maintenant qu'il faut qu'il
faut que ça finisse le pour qu'on puisse
commencer quelque chose d'autre avec en
acceptant les imperfections du travail
qu'on fait parce que dans les
imperfections si il ya des indices de ce
que nous sommes de ceux qu'on veut
devenir de maquiller pour moyens il ya
beaucoup d'intérêts aussi d'en cesser la
musique c'est ben des affaires dans ce
qu'on dit mais bien des affaires dans
dans ce qu'on dit pas aussi le sentiment
de vouloir continuer de travailler ou
pour commencer je te mentir je pense je
pense à prévenir de deux places à peut
venir d'être extrêmement critique de
deux tons or puis de vouloir constamment
raffiné parce que t'es pas passer bon ça
pour finir du doute qui peut être pas
positif puis un qui peut être super qui
peut travailler parce que jeunes à leurs
doutes des fois des fois c'est super bon
tout le monde se dit que c'est super bon
mais l'insécurité fait que qui
continuent de travailler où tu sors peu
au dessus et était satisfait mais dans
le fond ces séjours d'insécurité parce
que c'est bon tu voudrais juste que
c'est ça c'est vrai à reconnaître cc
dessus ces tubes die
c'est une la critique constructive où
c'est l'insécurité bandol et
l'association avec un bon un bon real
un bon directeur artistique qui va être
capable de cette personne là aussi peut
t'amener dans le dans le fossé aussi
nous des fois c'est elle qui va
idéalement c'est cette personne qui te
ramène sur la route qui est capable de
ramasser des meilleures idées puis dit
inquiet c'est seul c'est sur le projet
était métis daniel bélanger il vous en
parlez de tunis devra m'intéressant
parce que c'est quand ils disent à
mandanne illustrer ce que beaucoup de il
ya beaucoup de métier beaucoup
d'expérience mais quand tu sais que
c'est pas parfait mais cinq qu'il faut
que ce soit 5 il faut que ce soit sur
intéressant avec sa métaphore de de
l'hémicycle c'est comme des fois je sais
qu'il une secte qui pédalent pitt
si la grève qui t'amène par le pape
choisit aller titiller le top au fait
que de lui c'est comme ça c'est comme
s'ils sont à s'imposer en fait que
c'était plus fort qu'il y avait eu
quelqu'un quitte à y faire quelque chose
ici comme il n'y a pas le choix de le
faire même s'il sait que peut-être
terrain par son public à me reposer ou
ici que c'est juste une force mais c'est
comme pour que je commence à être reçu
mais je pense que c'est très en fait
c'est sûr c'est très instinctif
puis faut savoir moi je suis de l'école
je pense de ce truc il faut savoir
lâcher prise c'est fini pire commencé
pour nous permettre d'avancer c'est sur
un plaque sur le plan créatif non si
serein l'individu un quartier comme ceci
fait puis on va ailleurs comme un énième
tournée de spectacles il faut que ça
arrête là faut que ça finisse faut que
ça finisse pour pouvoir commencer autre
chose parce que sinon mais tu sais tu
deviens
en fait c'est de ne jamais se sentir sur
le sur le pilote automatique loin les
certains humoristes le tic enterrant du
xve 400 foule s'écroule c'est vraiment
c'est aux étoffes de pas de parti ne pas
tomber
l'automatique et j'imagine
j'imagine pas qui s'est trouvé là sa
zone moi c'est un peu ça le défi trouver
la zone où août et où tu es bien piteux
5 km 8,5 tavannes spx a le sentiment
d'être prêt pour faire quelque chose
puis de foot avant ce fauteuil avancer
un peu plus avant de le faire c'est
comme prendre le truc à la voir parce
que c'est de faire la chose de faire le
projet quitte valence et puis même si on
a tout un ami j'ai l'impression qu'ils
qu'ils y amener jean ferrat l'album ou
amman les manifestants de joindre mon
recueil de poésie et puis le projet dix
ans plus tard à amman et je vois faire
déjà fait le sel tipi sap après le meti
sera jamais prêt et serait jamais prêt
faut que tu fasses il faut que je fasse
des erreurs puis faut que tu sortes de
quoi qui pose qui est pas la meilleure
chose que l'univers inconnu sauf qu'il a
les toits par un autre à préparer ses
caisses ces temps c'est quand même
beaucoup plus le fun pensé le faire
c'est faux foglia seul c'est le fan
penser et créer des espaces iphone gaza
écrit combien de fois je me suis dit
comment je vais écrire un livre c'est
comme si le fait d'écrire des chansons
valider le fait que c'est vraiment s
c'est un c'est une autre forme adore
même quasiment écrit des chansons versus
écrire la poésie ces deux expériences
qui sont pour moi pas du tout les même
si c'est pour les mêmes façons pour
arriver avec eux
puis faut que tu organises ta vie de
bonheur à l'idée d'écrire un livre mais
faute de blocs trois heures par jour
dont je m'assois j'écris mon lit ou le
type parce que tu as mal de gars qui est
sa job de jours piqué y arriver puis
soir c'est que les enfants puis qu'ils y
mord faire mon album petit bloc pas de
tente projet mais dans l'album si c'est
exact m
et surtout comme quand la vie quand
steve hill dont tu parles embarque
beatty fini ta journée job bispo dit que
c'était trois heures de gaz encore à
tous les soirs pour faire avancer un
autre projet c'est le shia leboeuf lui
qui disait do we just dance est
différent c'est le meilleur conseil
étiez parce que d'expérience fidèles
avec un succès plus ou moins grande
ce que j'ai fait dans ma vie mais ton le
les seules fois ça a marché pour vrai
c'est quand j'ai fait quelque chose
puis j'ai testé ou au moment du leader
ouais c'est ça on va attendre paul
goulet c'est le studio existerait pas le
podcast extrait patience
si on n'avait pas fait beau la seconde
parce qu'on sent que marley j'ai encore
une fois j'en ai des amis que c'est
comment j'aimerais ça me paraît pas de
caracas a fait 3-1 pas de casse qui deux
semaines après le podcast et en ligne
quand on est le premier je suis faire le
phare épines
ce creusement 1 300 soit complet avec ce
conte ce qu'on disait au début de deux
quand je regarde derrière toi tu
regardes qui peuvent fait ici remplis
d'imperfections l'étudiant c'est une
zone dévolue premier épisode on l'écouté
on réécoute sur le pis c'est pas juste
pas optimale et non mais c'est ça qui
est en même temps il ya comme un homme
il ya une énergie là dedans
j'en ai mais aussi sur kiki qu'on reçoit
qui souffre souvent matin j'écoutais le
premier disque des trois accords le
premier disque de fou qui sait il ya
comme de quoi dans le premier disque de
ligny première je poste un pays où son
premier album ce qui est vraiment fait
avec grand chose gaye et le look
l'énergie que là dedans c'est
complètement un parfait mais ça témoigne
d'une groove d'une ambiance de
guinguette chemin
d'ailleurs il ya un jargon le ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'éléments qui
fonderait ok ça ça nous parle c'est ça
nous interpelle
pis c'est comme c'est juste le lexique
hommes comme vous dites c'est le geste
le faire le frère pour dit à irin
m'engage je le fais je prends le risque
puis le lit on l'a on le reçoit son leur
sens bien ça s'explique pas ça c'est
quelque chose qui se
qu'ils visent pour ce qu' il ya une
partie de moi dans d'un travail qui est
toujours c'est pas la quête de refaire
si on parlait au début du podcast on
parlait de du danger de refermer
mais qui est qui qui étiez vraiment
comme pour moi dans le piège
mais cet apport de risque de montrer
qu'ils qui on est ce que ce que je suis
devenu tellement sur mon dernier disque
la plupart des chansons on les a faites
en matière pires répressions
c'est lyon une bien chez nous a rejoints
guitare-voix dakar par le processus
c'est un rite envoie ko l'imac y est
puis les chansons guy dubois puis il ya
comme de quad en moins qui chante assise
sur un tabouret devant deux micros avec
ma guitare
on n'est pas capable de reproduire avec
un clic
puis où on chante pas pareil quand je
joue de la guitare méchant poche mais sa
main parfaitement mais quand je pars
fait que beaucoup de chansons qui sont
captés guitare voix - c'est la presse
herman faut que j'accepte guerre at-elle
complet il ya telle note ceux qui
cherchent ils à telle place dans le
temps si c'est un parfait mais c'est là
on dirait que ça respire et saluer
puis il y avait comme une peur d'eux une
part de vérité là-dedans mais oui c'est
ce qui me faisaient de hockey ce pur -
présentement ça a du sens sable alors je
me sens pau 1 1 ne sont pas protégés
comme si je suis dans un but de
chantepie que je refais pour capter
quelque chose qui plus est plus parfait
je pense que les gens ça c'est pas vrai
pour chaque projet c'est mauvais pour
chaque affaire mais pour moi c'est le
qu'on dirait que ça c'est là que ça se
passe quand il contient ce qui arrive
mais c'est 2
de le trouver elle accepte d'être bois
qui d'accepter quelques exemples ça va
être
c'est moi mais il s'est passé un long
processus de travail d'écriture de
réécriture de faire des maquettes
d'enregistrer quand même en dehors des
forces il doit recommencer de norbord
mais c'est vraiment le fun c'est
vraiment le faire si le le spectre de
l'imperfection c'est c'est de trouver le
sweet spot là dedans tu sais pas ce que
je dis dit mettons un point chaud puis
chanteur faut selon amman et ça dérange
le tir a mené il ya un bout d'os que la
perfection est tellement grande que
l'émotion passe plus il était si je
s'agaçant c'est juste pis versus des
fautes de quelque chose de trop parfait
le lytro 3,73 quintiles est justement ça
pue la vraie vie et puis d'émotion qui
passe non plus après ça ça dépend si des
genres des styles de se trouver l'espèce
des moments que pour cette chanson le
2-2 justement sur les spectres cette
chanson le team et ont tagué de vous
apprendre que cit avait faussé tout le
long de la haie repris tsinghua mais
qu'il faut c'est une place ou qui
allaitent avoir craqué une place où
campe la d14 juste tout genre juste
l'espèce de de sweet spot où est-ce que
l'émotion passe parce qu'il ya une
fragilité que ça coïncide avec le texte
avec la musique ceux ci c'est qu'il faut
trouver une seconde offre aussi à éviter
fois celle en effet une fois que
déterminée qui à qui ça va être comme ça
c'est comme la chanson la somme dont on
parle est tantôt été a été capté comme
ce ben je sais pas combien de fois je
suis retournée et maintenant celle ayant
engendré un studio pour commencer puis
c'est tout korek unis version métier
c'est le galliard des appels léon et
elle appuie andré papanicolaou mon ami
réalisateur tel qu'on dirait qu'on le
säntis après avoir fait l
j'en ai pu refaire d'après ce que nous
ayons le hall b ci-dessus il ya
c'est quelque chose de particulier
autour de cet éclat ou stella tech u18
de cette journée le statec que j'arrive
hymne un micro ou jazz un peu on le fait
parce qu'on y ont le tellement on l'a
tellement fait que mandanne et des plus
dans les mêmes considérations qu'au
début c'est donc ton figure pequena ta
voix le texte est intégré fait que les
notes commence a été intégré je peut
l'interpréter la déportation mais dans
mon cas si ça prend ça prend un temps
surprenante soit prendre le ton louis
jean cormier qui est un très très grand
talent lui ils vont avoir besoin
potentiellement de moins de temps pour
arriver à 1 1 1
un aussi bon ou un meilleur niveau
d'interprétation
puis soudain c'est chacun chacun ça
chacun sa démarche
chacun son sauveteur spi fait c'est
juste de trouver pour moi ça prend comme
un acte un contexte des fois c'est un
lieu les place tahrir
hassan ben des places et arrive où tu te
sens bien piètre on a fait la majorité
du dernier disque dans mon genre loft à
montréal chum
c'est une pièce qui que rien dedans dans
ce sens car il ya un lien weaver dans
pièce qui ya des chars qui passe pas
loin qui ont travaillé avec les mêmes
micro conclu avec le podcast considère
le classique puis mais quand j'étais
avec papanicolaou puis on était on
travaille et on avait tellement de fans
anti la lave on arrêtait en écouter des
disques ont allègrement à céder la
bouffe pas loin puis c'est adam né comme
quasiment un mode c'est un mode de winne
qui a abandonné sa s'installe dans dans
les trains qui des chansons puis le
c'est comme s'il est ou non comme une
respiration puis ça devient quelque
chose au t5
puis le libre et que s'installe une
après l'autre la maison c'est à la
maison se bâtit mais c'est aussi sur des
serrures qu'ils nous ont menés à ce 10 %
ça prenait ça prenait des moyens mais ça
prenait surtout du temps ça prend de la
patience puis c'était vraiment c'est
l'expérience humaine qui dans notre coup
dans mon cou qui rentre un peu dans dans
l'étreinte dans la musique puis que ça
s'apprend vie ça prend vie comme ça mais
ça c'est dans mon c tellement c'est
tellement personnel tu es tu sais 2 - et
pour eux n'importe où pour le projet
appui ça doit être ça aussi c'est
maintenant je pense à tout comme real
est atteint quand arrivait qu'un artiste
puisse faire qu'il cette personne là
comment je fais pour eux
pour la mener parce que le chemin soit
pas le même nom que pour l'artiste
précédent où l'artiste qui bosse ou ivre
s'est fixé chaque voix
la boîte de thoune on est un peu une
équipe c'est sûr je pense les meilleurs
real c'est eux qui sont le mieux capable
de comprendre la personne avec qui qui
travailleraient comment cette personne
ne travaille comment comment extrader
personnes le tout sont joints finalement
le tout son temps naissance puis salade
et naturel du pij sauce et puis fax et
si si vraiment c'est une job un peu de
tout petit moteur parce qu'il n'y a pas
de personnes qui qui qui en eau de
l'autre mais de t'avoir aidé à leur
égard une conversation qui fait qu'on
grandit tout le dépit de ces artistes
qui ont des histoires de tester avec ce
goal opi lui c'est comme il voulait
faire ce pitre valeurs d'antan l'artiste
est il pas respecté pis si ça fait que
je pense c'est d'être capable de mettre
l'artiste le plus à l'aise possible
d'aller me raconte son passé de beaucoup
de psychologie la dame vraiment plus
psychologique beaucoup de discussions il
ya beaucoup de ce que toute politique
qui t'avait des discussions au chômage
sur la vie avec un martelé
l'indicé c'est ça aussi le processus
créatif c'est se connaître soi même
mieux c'est ce qu'à réfléchir sur la vie
après ça se transpose dans l'orne film -
qui sait comme d'accepter si je me
rappelle quand on faisait des me disent
que j'ai fait un disque s'appelle chacun
dans son espace en 2003 puis le repas
tranquille en 2006 qui ont été des
disques vraiment important pour moi dans
mon cheminement puis je travaillais avec
m
à cette époque là avec un but qui
s'appelle éric goulet qui était un
premier mentor pour moi qui m'a amené à
découvrir plein de musique puis avec un
preneur de son qui s'appelle bien gérant
c'est vraiment des artistes
exceptionnels puis des fois chanté dans
le foot ça marchait pas au pied on
partait sais c'est drôle parce que dans
un quartier où se trouve le temps tu es
vraiment studiolo vous avez pas connu
toutefois convenu à la victoire est elle
au no 8 ans il y avait vraiment besoin
de tous les musiciens qui s'y rendre
parce qu'on a enregistré c'était je me
rappelle de chacun dans son espace on
l'a fait sur duteil pousser et donc
c'est un autre façon de d'enregistrer
mais quand ça marche et pau on partait
on allait prendre un verre on jase et
puis on venait puis présent gens
retournaient dans le bout de chanter
puis ayant donné ok mais oui c'est ça
c'est ici c'est tellement ça c'est
d'être capable de reconnaître justement
ce pot de fer vittek de plus qu'on a
besoin il essaie d'aller prendre marche
moi même si ses autres sites pilotes
studio narbonne à l'album c'est ça c'est
si faux que lille soit bien il faut
l'abattre soit bonne pour que la magie
sport ce lundi puissiez pas ce seuil est
grosse partie de la job de reals aussi
c'est d'ailleurs ce match parce que non
mais aussi sitôt posé la base métiers
issus parce que tu es ceux des
générations là aussi parce que tu serais
peut-être pas sûr que tous les
réalisateurs de toutes les époques et s
map était si gentil que renault
comme il ya eu des époques de réals ou 2
chanteurs sous le portrait d époque
dorée à se parler il vous donnera du
temps sur le parquet mais par contre
j'ai persuadé que tu as raison je pense
que la bonne façon c'est trouver là la
zone où l'artiste surtout c'est vrai
dans l'enregistrement de une performance
des performances musicales mais ça se
passe beaucoup d'en trouver la vérité
dans la voix
loin de la personne celles vraiment que
ça c est la signature souvent et le beau
temps dans la puissance vocale plus que
dans la couleur la couleur de la boi
leur de du duflot de la personne
mais oui pythie des fois ça vient tu
aimais tant qu'enjeu réussi avec ariane
elle vraiment une idée claire de de son
interprétation mettons nos types d comme
un carburant de la toune phi phi phi ce
a6 a6k sans vos biens puis on sait on
n'a pas beaucoup de sirop que je
voudrais qu'ils essayent la moindre
erreur plus derrière plus d'1m tout de
même métier que je fais ce travail là
avec un autre projet qui est que j'ai
faite petit jeu de chant des paramètres
c'est d'essayer de trouver justement le
sweet spot de qui on le sait plus d'où
on laissait plus fort on essaye plus
comme ça plus comme ceux des fois une
journée à l'auto si les tractations
change la voix change pileux amanites
fait c'est comme ça c'était comme s'il
fallait que la team soir à 18 heures
puis l'ont lu le team est de 6,6 est
vraiment à cela ce qui est fascinant là
dedans c'est là la porte des mystères
mais c'est ce que c'est exactement ça
c'est un bowling musique c'est une
émotion c'est le finaliste et l'art en
général c'est parce qu'elle c'est vrai
c'est vrai dans la musique mais c'est
vrai c'est le cinéma c'est vrai dans les
arts visuels métiers se met-il le but
c'est pas d'avoir 100% comme un exemple
neuf bus etc et écoute ce que tu vivre
quelque chose de typique et sa touche
que tu vives une émotion qui était que
cette transposition visa moi je pense au
japon comme je vis comme une sorte de
rencontre
si on voit dessus on vas tu rencontré
quand je quand j'écoute un album on
dirait que si je rends dans un dans un
univers c'est fake
si l'artiste des fois je tends symbiose
avec un artiste x ou y parce que je sens
que j'ai les clés pour montréal et puis
j'embarque dans sa sa proposition puisse
auxerre ça s'explique tu sais quelque
chose qui se vit simplement ça
s'explique pas toujours pierre
mais quelle chance pareille
quelle chance de façon à ce que ça me
fait quand on finissait des journées qui
sont vraiment on est chanceux de voir si
on est chanceux de pouvoir s'exprimer
surtout dans 1 1
on est quand même dans un micro marché
oui demain cccc traité unique où est ce
qu'on vise c'est peut-être des suédois
ou des finlandais qui vivent à moins
qu'ils font de la musique qui qui vit ou
de ce que moi je vis mais sinon ce sont
peu nombreux ont évalué dans un aussi
petit marché puis d'avoir des gens qui
s'intéressent à ce qu'on fait mais
qu'ils viennent voir les spectacles des
spectacles ils ont qui sont fiers d'eux
qu'ils sont fiers aussi delà de leur
culture pillon qui ont besoin car non à
quelque part il ya le carnot besoin
qu'un qui ont besoin de ce parce que
tellement un autre rapport plus intime
c'est quand quelqu'un chante dans
parents qui viens viens de voir dans ta
ville
pis c'est un autre c'est un tout autre
toute autre expérience qu'elle voit un
chaussant d'instance qui débarque c'est
un rapport alors pierre la musique qui
complément différent que met-on leur
international qui nous arrive exactement
c'est comme si la musique québécoise il
personnes dans le monde m'apportes les
québécois kim incapable de se
l'approprier comme jeu qui manqua pas de
l'écouter sombre on parlait jeu m'avait
le plus c'est quand même et qu'on essaie
d'imaginer quelqu'un qui parle pas
nécessairement le français ou qui
parlent le français assez pour
comprendre que débarque ici qui entend
justement une tonne de jean leloup le
genre oui lille qui entend we leave fait
que pour les coudes pendant tout l'été
mais c'est quoi ce qui pourrait quand
même à cause du sang à cause de tes
comme harmonium des années soixante dix
il pourrait non pour ce rôle mais pour
apprécier initialement la chanson
évidemment jamais couru pour comprendre
c'est quoi les références culturelles
mais il ya quand même de quoi où il aime
la musique comme étant car ces derniers
même très très très régional défaut
selon elle plus proche de quelque chose
d'interdît international ti m6 est
vraiment c'est être un show de la
capacité que la musique est de
transcender une langue ou un des
frontières mais tu as raison par contre
que elle n'est pas elle n'est pas perçue
comme de la même artiste tchèque qui
comme ultra populaire la baule qui en
europe de l'est mais que j'entends sur
puis cgg hockey auquel codes pour être
capable de comprendre pourquoi d'un
artiste qui célébrait autant que
souhaité j'en passe et codes
des fois super mettons des fois tu vois
c'est vraiment et l'espèce des copies de
tous nos amis tiennent avec un coq
chante dans sa langue natale de timmins
de supputer c-max écolo c'est comme sûr
que tu reconnais musique métier ou si
comme moi tu sais si tu déjà vu des gens
tout juste comme remarcher alors jean
leloup taille diminue il ya des exemples
de foi de l'artiste y mettons et stromae
blanc que donner votre musique en france
un succès international
c'est le jeune fille une espagnole ros
alliotte ces faits comme le mélange de
pop avec de la musique flamenco en fait
c'est cathala ses pieds ça marche folle
du diabète québécois c'est elle qui
adore les syndiqués qui sont signés sur
les balles américaines stop au plus
qu'il est bon de se piquer qui touche
c'est qui qui qui ce qui touche un
public et pas nécessairement
francophones mais mais c'est sauvé mais
c'est vrai qu'on est quelque chose de
vraiment je pense unique puis bopi
particulier au québec le ticket est
quand même somme toute par capitaux
beaucoup d'artistes l'impression d'un
tipi et beaucoup d'or beaucoup
d'humoristes beaucoup de titres je pense
que le fait qu'on veut exister fécond
qu'on crie beaucoup je pense soigne
assure qu' on ne sait pas ce pas
toujours parfait mais l'arrêt quand même
supporter on aurait au québec puis au
canada et ce qui est pas le cas d'un je
pense pas que ce soit les codes 1 dans
tous les pays c'est que ce soit soutenue
comme comme comme ça l'est chez nous ce
qui nous permet de continuer à
ce qui nous permet de continuer à
innover puis ce qui nous permet de
continuer surtout exist in parce que ça
parle beaucoup moi je pense que ça passe
beaucoup beaucoup par sa wii savoure sa
merci infiniment
les gens l autre pote tu pars en tournée
selon l'étude et bien encore des billets
c'est sûrement bon site internet mais
samia point qu'à mener la tournée et le
grande tournée pour pour l'année à venir
show solo que je trimballe vraiment
partout partout au québec dans des
centres culturels qui dans les plus
petites elles aussi fait que j'invite
les rennais féret pardon merci
énormément pour dresser un des beaux
podcast qu'on a fait
dernièrement je trouve un je trouve
vous faites vraiment vous faites
vraiment un super job
bien sûr ce métro ans que j'aime j'aime
beaucoup votre terrain très en arrêt
dans le procès sans l'accusé
merci merci d'avoir écouté ses podcasts
jusqu'à la fin j'espère que vous avez
apprécié la conversation ça prouve que
vous êtes de réelles fans de
conversation et du sans-fil pas de
casser on vous remercie vraiment
beaucoup
si vous voulez avoir plus de contenus
plus de conversations sur pétillante que
ça se passe ce qui est sûr p tu es a non
seulement on met tous les podcasts en
ligne au moment où est ce qu'on les
tombes donc on a beaucoup de semaine
d'avant sur le pga mais on fait aussi
des encore moins de filtres qui sont
exclusifs aux membres pétuaud nous est
ce que on parle d'homme n'est que l'émoi
de la conversation qu'ont bien d'avoir
ce qu'on met un peu plus en profondeur
dans certains sujets qu'on voulait
aborder ou qu'on a abordé pendant le
podcast donc
allez sur notre page de turenne et le
lien vers ce havre dans la description
du podcast qui remercie encore une fois
de nous avons écouté jusqu'à la fin